Hello, everyone.
I'm not okay, but, like, here we are.
Okay, so, if I knew... Alright, so we were just notified, like, like, five minutes before 9, 8, I'm not alive.
I'm technically, I'm the definition of alive, but inside, I can feel myself slowly.
Drifting away.
Whoa.
I'm not okay.
Damn.
So... Sorry, I just blew my nose.
Okay, so I have to go straight into it because... Alright, five minutes before...
Guys, I would love to do, like, our usual life update, but, like, five minutes before 9 a.m., we were given, like, I got notified, like, like, the order.
Of which this, um, early access was gonna go.
And, like, you know, I assume we're gonna...
We could take this on our own pace with seeing everything.
But I guess 30 minutes in the training area, I guess, before they shut it...
I don't fucking know how they shut it down, but...
I guess it's just... I mean, this is the internal build.
They can do whatever the fuck they want.
But I get 30 minutes of training area... practice range.
If I knew that it starts with an hour and a half of arenas, I would have started later.
Because I do not want to play arenas.
I...
Personally...
Do not want to play arenas.
Because I was not a huge fan of arenas.
But maybe...
Maybe they made it...
They improved it since the last time arenas came to be.
Um...
So...
It's...
Like, an hour and a half of arenas.
And then we get Battle Royale at 11.
And I was thinking...
Oh my god.
I have to be strong enough to play until 11.
So I can try the Battle Royale vote.
I was like...
You can do it, Doki.
You are strong.
You can...
You can play.
You can stay up till...
Guys, I had three hours of sleep, for those who are wondering.
I...
What was I doing?
Um...
To...
To garnish three hours of sleep?
Well...
I...
Was actually practicing Apex!
Because I haven't touched Apex in a long time!
So...
I...
Thought it was such a good idea...
To practice Apex.
All right.
There's the new hero.
There he is.
I'm sorry.
I know I should be like more...
Like, you know...
Whoa, guys!
Look at this!
I'm sorry.
I'm...
Obviously, it's nine in the morning right now for me.
So I'm not okay right now.
I...
Have...
Practice...
I...
Guys!
No!
Okay, cool.
Okay, that's pretty cool.
I'm a double jump.
Um...
You never learn, do you?
No.
Also, like...
Obviously, I had a convention today.
Okay, or yesterday, technically.
But, um...
My...
I had to do a convention in Australia.
Yesterday.
It was great.
I love doing conventions.
I love Mean Dragoons around the world.
But then, you know...
Obviously, the smart thing to do...
Was to sleep afterwards.
But instead...
Also, oh my gosh.
I have a double jump.
Oh, it's like the Ash ability.
But instead of going forward...
I go up.
Whoa!
Um...
I mean, that's nice movement-wise.
Uh...
And...
Double jump and...
Wall pounce.
Yeah, I heard about that.
Wait, how do I do that?
What the fuck?
Did I get wall pounce?
What?
Are you sure?
Are you...
Are you sure about that?
Oh, I see it.
I see the notification.
You have to climb.
And then...
You...
You get your double...
Oh, okay.
That's...
That's cool.
It's this.
And then you jump on it.
And then you can have a double jump right here.
So, look.
I can reset it.
Wait, wait.
What?
Wait, I can reset it.
Okay.
Wait, did I just reset it?
Okay, wait.
Let me try this out.
Okay.
Okay, no.
I thought I could reset it, but it was because of this.
So, it's basically like...
Wait.
And then I jump.
And then...
Okay, wait.
Did I use it?
Oh, wait.
What?
Okay.
I could climb this wall forever if I wanted to, technically.
Yeah.
I could climb this wall forever if I wanted to.
I think I can.
And then...
Yeah.
Okay.
By the time...
Technically, I can climb this wall forever if I wanted to.
So, we Genji now.
Yeah.
We Genji.
Uh...
But, okay.
Where was I?
So, like...
The smart decision right after doing convention is to head to bed.
But instead, I was like...
I should practice Apex.
Because it's been a while since I've played this game.
So, like, you know...
I should really, you know...
Know what the fuck I'm doing.
I should have read his abilities.
Give me a sec.
Um...
What are his details?
He has to double jump.
Press jump while in the air.
Jump again.
Press jump while climbing.
We'll launch Sparrow up the wall.
By the way, his name is Sparrow, for those who don't know.
Um...
My throat is warming up right now.
Hmm.
Uh...
Carry additional arrows and explosive arrows for the bow check.
Okay, so...
The bow check is on the ground now.
But...
For what?
Right?
Let me get my cough drops.
Um...
They changed how the bow check works.
So, I have no idea how they changed it.
But we'll see there.
So, the tracker dart...
I have, like, 15 minutes left of the training range before I get kicked out, I believe.
So, that's cool.
Oh...
So, I'm trying to...
I'm trying to get through this as much as I can.
Before...
Before they're, like...
Knock, knock!
It's arena time!
Um...
Shoot a tracker.
For a godlock that reveals enemies who walk within its line of sight.
These darts can be used to activate...
Oh!
Oh, okay.
They can activate survey beacons.
Okay, so...
Oh, is he...
Is he Scottish?
Okay, so...
How does this work, technically?
How does this work?
Okay, so...
So, I guess I'll see whoever's there?
That enemy's being tagged.
Okay.
All right.
This really helped.
I already have, like...
I can see people.
Oh, he's Italian.
Okay.
I couldn't tell...
First off...
At first...
But, like...
Okay, he's Italian.
All right.
Yeah, his first...
The first thing he said sounded Scottish.
I was like, is he Scottish?
Okay, so...
That tracks them.
Oh, okay.
Now it sees two of...
Okay.
Okay, so he's, like...
Obviously, he's a scouter.
With the whole fucking name and everything.
Oh, mama...
Mama mia.
Ba-da-ba-da-da.
Ba-ba-ba-ba-da-da.
Ba-ba-ba-da-da-da.
My mind is, like, full-on...
Oh, everywhere right now.
To the large arrow that will anchor where it lands after it charges up, it will shock anyone within its range, causing damage and slowing its enemies on hit.
Oh, my God.
I'm trying to...
I'm a mess right now.
I'm trying...
It's 9 in the morning.
Oh, my God.
I'm just trying to grab tissue to blow my nose.
Okay.
To the large arrow, causing damage and slowing any enemy.
Also, sound guy.
It's been a while since I've sound adjusted for Apex.
So, let me know if it's okay.
Because I don't know if I saved my volume for that.
All right.
Charging it up.
And then I'm going to hit him.
And then...
What the fuck?
Okay.
Whoa.
How long is that?
Oh, that's not cool.
I definitely would not want to get hit by that.
I'm just like, wait.
That does not...
I mean, it's cool if you get that chance.
Okay.
If I hit this here...
All right.
That's not...
That's not cool.
Okay.
All right.
That is like...
That seems strong.
Oh, the arrow can be destroyed if I hit somebody.
Can it be destroyed if I hit someone?
Oh, it's out of fire.
Okay.
Let's see.
I want to know if it goes through walls.
No, it doesn't.
That's good to know.
It doesn't go through buildings.
All right.
Okay.
At least it can be destroyed.
You know?
It can be...
All right.
Imagine if it did...
Yeah, I was going to say.
If it actually went through walls, then we're cooked.
Wait a minute.
Wasn't that guy from inside the building?
Okay.
I need to double check if it does go through walls or not.
Because that guy was in the building.
All right.
Where is a man in the building so we can double check it?
Do we have any bots in buildings?
Okay.
Let's see.
We have any men in buildings, please.
All right.
I'll do it here and then see if it goes through this.
Okay.
Nice.
It doesn't.
All right.
That's cool.
It doesn't go through.
Nice.
Yay.
Can it destroy doors?
Oh, that's a good question.
Let's try and find out if it does.
All right.
Yeah.
It needs...
I think it doesn't...
It really needs line of sight because, like...
I guess it can work.
If I shoot above it, if I shoot above it, I feel like if I shoot above this building, will it hit this guy over here?
Let's find out.
All right.
It needs line of sight.
Is it still on the ground?
Oh, it is.
So, yeah.
It's still on the ground.
So, we can... That's good.
Alright.
It doesn't stick to you.
So, uh...
That's good.
Because if it didn't stick to you, it's like the OG Arc Star Strap.
Where you Arc Star yourself, and then your teammate Arc Stars you.
And then you run into the team.
Like, I was wondering if it's something like that.
But, like, not as broken.
Look, guys.
Not as broken.
It seemed a little scary at first.
But now that we tested it out, it's not as bad as I thought it'd be.
Um, this just needs...
If it can be broken...
The only issue is, like, I wonder how strong this is to break.
Is it like a rocket ult?
Where, like, it's easy to break?
Or is it, like, a Groot Wall?
Where I cannot fucking break that shit if I want...
If my entire family line tries to hit it.
Like...
I just need to know that.
Um...
Alright, what other stuff?
It's...
Okay, so, like...
It's so awkward.
Because, like...
When I was, like, playing this game...
I was playing with, like...
When I was trying to practice Apex before the early access...
Okay, I have...
Sorry, I'll give you this...
I'll give you this conversation when I...
Before they kick me out of the...
The practice range.
Because...
I have, like, 10 minutes left of practice range.
Where the...
Where the fuck is the bow check?
Okay, there it is.
Alright, bow check.
Alright, so, for those who don't know...
Uh, Sparrow is OP'ing up.
Let's nerf Doctor Strange to the ground.
Psycho...
And the doctor...
And then the Marvel rival is gonna have a...
A fucking random patch note that comes open.
It was like...
Guys, looking at the current...
Uh...
Trajectory of other games...
We're gonna nerf...
A doctor's change.
Alright, for those who don't know...
Bow check...
Now comes with 50 arrows...
Right off the bat.
So...
You can't...
The only way to get more Bow check ammo...
Is you gotta pick up your arrows.
So it's like a Hawkeye situation.
Where you're wondering...
How does Hawkeye keep having arrows?
Um...
But what he does...
Is that after he kills somebody...
He goes over...
And picks up his arrows.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, and then he gets it back.
So...
So, like...
You can also pick up other people's Bow check arrows.
Um...
So...
You know...
Sorry, I missed that.
It's 9am, guys.
So you have to go over...
And be like...
Guys, I'm running out of arrows, guys.
And then you go and go...
And you pick it up.
Wait, where's my fucking...
Oh, it's cause I missed.
I don't know where my missed arrow is.
I...
What even misses?
Well, that arrow's gone.
I don't know where it left.
Cause it's like...
Look, see?
Every arrow...
Can this crash the server?
Imagine if like...
How many arrows does it take to crash the server?
Like, I'm curious.
Do they disappear?
Is it...
Like, wait a minute.
Wait, can I crash the server?
Like this?
How long does it take before they disappear?
How many arrows will it take?
And how many times do we have to miss to crash the server?
Oh...
Oh, God.
Only one way to find out.
I'm just wondering.
If everybody had bow checks.
And we all just collectively shot our bow...
All 50 bullets of our bow check ammo.
Will it crash the server?
That's my...
That's a game theory.
I like to test out.
Like...
Alright.
What are my explosive arrows?
How do I...
How do I use my...
Oh, I need a frag grenade for it.
Okay.
Plus, I wonder.
How do I use my explosive arrows?
Hey, where the fuck are frag grenades put in?
Okay.
I need to grab it here.
Maybe.
I don't know.
It's a...
It's a good thought to have.
Okay.
Gain an extra...
Alright.
How do I...
Okay.
B...
Oh, so it's like...
The sentinel.
It's basically like a sentinel.
Alright.
And then...
Oh.
That's...
That's scary.
They're like...
Ha ha.
He missed.
And then it's like...
Did I...
I...
That's a little scary.
It's like mini ballistic right there.
Oh, dear.
Alright.
Oh, there you go.
Time to pick up my arrows.
Guys.
It's Hawkeye time.
Let me pick up my arrows.
Whoa.
Alright.
Nice.
Um...
No, I don't.
I...
I went back and picked it up.
Can you...
Oh, yeah.
Can I super...
That's a good question.
Can you super jump with a...
You know what?
You're right.
There's no dumb...
Dumb questions.
I can hurt myself.
Ha ha ha.
Alright.
I can hurt myself, guys.
Um...
Oh, there you go.
See?
Look at that.
Goodbye.
Ha ha ha.
Wait.
That's not even 30 minutes.
What do you mean?
That wasn't even 30 minutes.
I should have three minutes.
Alright, guys.
Guys.
Knock...
Okay.
What was I talking about?
I can stall a little bit before I have to do arenas.
It's...
Ha ha ha.
Alright.
What was I talking about before I was like...
Wait, guys.
Let me, like, try out the bow shape before they kick me out.
Um...
Ha ha ha.
Okay.
What was I...
What was I talking about?
What did I want to talk about before...
Before, like...
I was like, guys, wait a minute.
I gotta...
I gotta try this out before...
Oh, yeah.
Um...
Oh, my God.
What was that topic that I...
Oh, yeah.
Uh...
I was playing with a friend a bit.
I don't know.
Like...
To practice Apex.
Um...
Before I went...
Before I had my three hours sleep.
Um...
And...
I was, like...
Getting these, like...
You know those error codes?
And stuff on your...
When...
If you don't, uh...
Get...
If you don't, like, get into the server correctly...
Here's these error codes that show up...
On your top right.
And then, like...
I...
For the life of me...
I could not remember any Apex terminology.
I just was, like...
I see...
I see symbols everywhere.
And I was just, like...
I don't know what these symbols mean anymore.
My brain is just Marvel rivals.
I forgot every...
Oh, my...
I was, like...
I don't remember these Apex terms.
The Apex lag.
And they're, like...
And then my friend was, like...
Oh, hey...
They're, like...
Blah, blah...
Oh, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And I was, like...
There's an Apex word for this.
Oh my god, what was it?
I don't remember.
And then at one point, I was like...
At one point, I was like, let's go to the point, guys.
And my friend was like, point?
I was like, sorry, zone, guys.
Let's go to the zone.
I was like, it's been too long.
She forgot her roots.
But guys, it's killing me right now.
What was it called when...
What is it called when you...
Oh my god, okay.
Encore, nice.
What is it called when you don't sync up to the Apex server correctly?
And you start lagging.
But it's not the internet.
I swear to god, I remember that word.
Packet loss!
Oh my god, thank you, Alan!
I was like, going crazy.
I was like, what the fuck was that word called?
I was having packet loss.
And I was like, I was so...
Like, it was so bad.
Like, and I like...
I was... I had to quit my game and log back in.
I was still getting packet loss.
And I was like, frustrated as hell.
And I was trying to tell my friend that I was like...
Oh my god, there's so many symbols.
And there's something happening to my...
To my... I didn't sync up to the server right now.
But I don't know what it's called.
And it's fucking killing me.
And then my friend gave zero good answers.
And I was like, no!
You're not...
Because I was like, you're not Apex enough.
You don't understand.
There's a special word for this.
There is...
No, it's a special Apex term.
Because it happens a lot to Apex people.
It's...
It's a mostly Apex term.
Because this game...
Because it happens a lot to Apex players.
So...
So I have to...
Like...
So it's...
Because...
I don't have to say Packet Loss in Marvel Rivals.
I don't have to say Packet Loss in Overwatch.
It happens a lot in Apex though.
So I remember saying a lot in Apex.
I...
Okay.
It's one of the Apex specials.
So I was just like, what was that word called?
Oh...
Therefore, it is an Apex term.
Exactly.
Alright, guys.
It's time to play.
Who will get Sparrow in arenas?
Alright.
It's unlike...
Can Doki survive an hour and a half of arenas?
Can she...
Can she make it out of arenas?
Oh, I missed the first queue.
God damn it!
I talk...
I should have queued up right after.
Why did I?
No!
Everyone is already in game.
I...
I missed...
I missed the first arena queue.
No!
Alright, guys.
I guess I should have...
I should have queued up before I went in arenas.
I really should have.
I just...
I didn't know.
I...
Oh, you're right, guys.
How long is the arenas, by the way?
Well, yeah, I think it is.
Guys, I don't even know.
Oh, it's me and...
Me and one other...
These other two players also took too long.
Let's go!
Oh!
Um...
Oh, my God.
I didn't realize I missed the first fucking queue.
I had to...
I had to talk about packet loss, guys.
I had to.
At least I'm not alone.
Oh, nice.
There we go.
Alright, it's time to play...
Who will get...
Who will get Sparrow first?
Yippee!
Alright, who's first choice?
God!
I'm last?!
Okay.
Oh, no one wants to play Sparrow?
I mean...
Fuck, okay.
I guess I'll take...
I guess it's like...
Cause, like, Sparrow's not that great in Arena.
So, like, it makes sense.
But, like, also, I...
Whatever.
Is he...
Bad?
I'm just like...
No one wants to play Sparrow?
Okay.
Maybe that's a...
Wait!
No one's playing Sparrow!
I...
I don't know!
You know what?
Let's go.
Let's buy that bow check.
I...
I was like...
Why is no one playing Sparrow?
I don't understand!
Do I need anything else?
Nah.
I don't.
I don't need anything else.
Honestly.
Okay.
Maybe I should not have put my grenade right off the back.
Oh, that was an accident!
Alright.
I bought a grenade.
I accidentally grenaded my bow check.
That was a fucking accident.
Alright.
That was very good.
Okay.
Where are they?
That was a fucking accident.
Whoops.
The buttons are fucked, but...
Figure this out.
Okay.
Stupid ballistic.
Oh, man.
Oh!
Oh, 158 on one!
Oh,
shit!
He's going in!
Oh, he's looking at me!
Alright.
That is...
Let's go!
Yeah!
I hit two shots!
I did it!
Is this fair?
I have like two technically who were Pred players before.
Wait, do I automatically... Okay.
I don't care.
I don't know.
Just get that R9 in there.
And then... Wait, can I not?
Previously purchased?
Wait, what?
I cannot use my... I can't use my... Is arenas not balanced?
No way!
Oh my god.
I can't buy two... Wait, but... Yeah, I can't buy two in a row.
Which I've noticed.
Yeah.
I'll just run... I guess I'll run R9.
No, I get... No, it's like you can't do it twice in a row.
Which is dumb?
Is that dumb?
Okay.
All right.
I'm running up.
Where are they?
What the fuck?
Okay.
All right.
This is not fair.
What the fuck?
Shit.
Is it lagging for you guys a little bit?
Like you're talking...
Okay.
Oh, I can.
If I... What?
Okay.
Every... Every gun is... All right.
You know what this means?
Wait, did they nerf Akimbo?
Let's find out.
We'll find out.
Okay.
If they did, I'm gonna... Grab... I don't know.
I guess the Havoc.
No, actually.
Don't waste my money on two guns.
We don't need it.
I'll... We don't need it.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Let's go.
Let's ult.
All right.
Nah.
Let's try it.
Are they gonna do the same thing?
Yes, they are.
Whoops.
That's not what I want to do, but that's fine.
We'll find out if they're still there.
There we go.
They didn't nerf that gun.
They did not nerf it.
I was like... You know what?
I don't even... There we go.
Oh.
Hey.
Wait, what?
There we go.
Hey, did these guys?
Guys.
I don't think my lobby... I don't think my team was fair.
I don't know who the fuck was on the other team, but they...
That's definitely a full three stack of, like, people who have hit Fred before.
Versus...
Versus... Who the fuck was... Yeah, I'm sorry.
DJ Sneaky Snake.
I... Sorry, buddy.
Yeah, that's awkward.
I don't mean... This is a full hydrogen bomb situation.
Yeah, the DJ Sneaky Snake and... Yeah, all these guys.
Sorry, buddy.
Definitely not... Not a fair game.
I was like... Oh, shit.
This is... My team's pretty decent.
I recognize these people.
And then... I just wanted to have a fun time.
Leave DJ alone till he's already dead.
Don't worry.
That's gonna be me on the enemy team.
I'm gonna fucking go against, like, um... Don't worry.
I'm gonna be put into, like, that exact situation very soon, guys.
I... I feel... I feel it.
I'm gonna get DJ Sneaky Snake on my team.
Oh, wait.
No.
Okay.
I got a caution again.
Uh...
Okay.
Not exactly the exact same situation.
Uh...
We don't... We don't have DJ Sneaky Snake, unfortunately.
You know, I'm gonna try...
I don't know how I feel.
I'm just playing Sparrow.
I'm just playing Sparrow just for the sake of...
The fact that I can play Sparrow.
Mmm.
I don't know who Maiden is, though.
I mean, that's good.
At least it could be less of a Hydrogen Bomb.
Hello.
Mmm.
Hello, how you doing?
I'm doing good as LAN.
Alright.
It's fun.
It's so fun.
Wait, can people at LAN try it out, too?
I'm really glad that you're having fun.
Hi, Doki.
Thank you.
Okay, let's see.
I don't know who these people are.
Like, on the end.
I...
Am I just out of touch?
Am I...
No.
Probably.
Am I out of touch, guys?
I don't know.
The only person I recognize is Caution.
Because he's been in the Apex team for so fucking long.
No, it's the kids.
Yeah.
I went wrong.
Let me go.
Yeah, dude.
I'm just like...
I don't recognize these names other than one person.
Alright.
Are they gonna go here again?
I swear to god.
Where are they gonna go?
No, they're over here.
I've got an opponent inside.
Step 5.
Setting a tracker.
Okay.
I have 50 bullets.
It's fine.
I know I should take high ground, but like, I'm bored.
Okay.
I'm gonna...
G this.
Oh.
What?
Oh my god!
Get back!
Oh!
Sorry, I...
I forgot my keybinds.
I forgot my keybinds, so I was like, freaking out.
Where's my...
I see them to my left.
I see them trying to get across.
So I was like...
See them trying...
What?
Okay.
They're actual players.
Oh no, this is bad.
For me.
Oh my god.
This is bad for me.
Are you playing on...
Oh, my god.
Oh, voice cut out.
What was it?
OH MY WATCH!
Yes, I'm done last!
Did you hear me now?
Alright, back to my roots.
Back to my roots.
Okay, let's see.
Yeah, I am.
Alright.
Baiting and...
Baiting!
I was looking at her cross!
There's someone to my left side!
I don't know how to press Q for this.
The tracker thing is so weird.
Maybe I'm just aiming it incorrectly.
Who are we fighting?
Like, I don't know.
It's Crusade.
I guess they're running as a team.
I guess that would make sense, right?
Jesus.
Okay, I hate this.
I hate this.
That they're so...
Missile locked!
Okay.
Not anymore.
Oh, there is a little lag.
I see it now.
Oh, wait.
Why am I on EU server?
Wait.
No, okay.
It's not EU server.
I think it's just like...
Just unfortunate.
Alright, I'm gonna take this 1v1 and lose.
Okay.
He ulted that.
But I couldn't...
Oh, it's 2 down?
Okay.
I believe her.
Alright, nice.
Yay!
Yippee!
I have 145 ping!
God!
I was like, wait a minute.
I see it now.
Alright, you know what would be great at 140?
No, I shouldn't risk that.
I was like, you know what would be amazing at that ping?
Alright.
Let's see.
Havoc time.
I have more money.
Yeah, let's just put it all on Havoc.
You know, fuck this.
If they're...
No, I can't snipe on that ping.
Alright.
I was gonna be like, fuck it.
Let's bring out the sniper.
I was like, wait, no.
This ping fucking sucks.
Alright.
I can't do that on that ping.
I'm gonna try.
I'll try it out one time.
Jesus.
I'm so bad at the tracker.
I've missed every time.
This is sick.
God damn it.
I see them.
I see them over here.
Jesus.
I cracked one of them.
Okay, maybe one gun was not it.
UGHHAHAHAHAHA!
Yes!
One gun might not be the best idea that I could do... in my life.
Oh my god.
What the fuck was shooting was?
There we go.
Yeah.
Let me...
I should not use one gun.
But you know what I'm going to do?
I'm going to keep using one gun.
I won't learn.
I won't learn from my mistakes.
I'll still do it.
One gun, I don't know why.
Okay, wait, but we win this.
It'll be fine.
So might as well bring this in too.
Might as well.
Let's go.
I can be your sniper or your close range.
Oh, wait.
There's no consequences.
Let me grab my ult too.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Let's just grab everything.
Alright, where are they heading to?
Jesus Christ.
I hate the scope on this though.
Jesus, I can tell the lag.
Me don't like you.
You know, like this lag.
Oh no, maybe this might be dumb.
There we go.
Where's the last guy?
Okay.
I may as well pull a heel.
It's fine.
Oh, hey.
Oh, we just got this, right?
Yeah, I was gonna say.
Yeah, there we go.
Nice meeting you.
There we go.
I got it.
See guys?
Who said I'm washed?
Look at that.
I just can't snipe with this ping.
We ignored like the 10 seconds of whiffing on the longbow.
But like, come on.
I did my job.
I did what I can.
Streamer, like, try again.
I don't know who she is now.
Oh, what's the watermark?
It's so that, like, you know, if people somehow leak stuff, they'll tell you.
It's just to prevent leakers.
Because it'll tell you, like, who it was that leaked.
Because this is early access and stuff like that.
So, it's to prevent leaking.
Or this.
Jesus, I wish it was like an hour.
Give me Battle Royale!
I don't want to play arenas.
I want a Battle Royale!
Give me, give me!
Let me in!
I'm tired of arenas already!
Yeah.
But we love arenas.
I was never...
And I'm going to say it.
I was...
Okay.
As long...
It would be funny if we fight against Caution now.
But, like...
I was never a fan of...
I was personally not a huge fan of arenas.
Because arenas had so many exploiters, um...
Playing.
So, like...
I didn't like arenas because of it.
There was a lot of hackers in arenas, too.
There was a lot of exploiters and hackers in arenas.
So, I never liked arenas because of it.
Because it was so easy to hack a pair...
Like, it was so easy to hack in arenas and not get caught.
Because it was so fast compared to Battle Royale.
I know, like, because I knew a friend who granted Arena Pred, and they were saying it was, like, very... Oh, I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
I knew it.
Caution would be there.
Oh, my God.
I knew it.
He's just gonna run in.
He's just gonna rush in.
I know it.
I know that's what he's gonna do.
I'm gonna just buy... Actually, no.
I don't wanna buy a naked R9 if he's just gonna fucking run in.
I'll just get Nemesis.
Fuck.
Ah.
Nemesis.
Fuck it.
Let's just get Nemesis.
I'm gonna... He's just gonna run straight in.
I don't know what my team's skill is, but Caution is, like, really... Caution's been playing this game since, like, launch.
So... And he's been high ranked since launch, so I'm, like, a little...
I'm a little hesitant on fighting him.
Because I know...
Skill-wise, he is better than me skill-wise.
I have no question asked.
He's been around for a while, so...
So I know skill-wise he is better than me, and that's, like...
What the fuck?
Oh, my God.
He can track me?
I don't know where exactly he is, so...
Gotta be careful right now.
Okay.
Okay, you got some defense.
Oh, my God.
I only have...
An enemy's here.
Idiot.
Fire on here.
No!
I didn't realize I had a second gun!
That's unlucky.
I knew you'd be dead.
I didn't realize I had a second gun.
I forgot it gave me an...
If I knew I had a Mozam, I would have ran in with my Mozam.
I found out that late.
I found out late that I had a Mozam.
Yeah.
Alright.
That's interesting.
Yeah, I forgot.
That's how little I play.
I told you, that's how little I play.
Okay, now that I have...
Now that I have, like, enough money, I'll naturally use this.
Yeah, I mean, he ran in a straight line.
I played very carefully there.
He ran...
He ran in a straight line for me.
Like, there was...
It was just...
There was no outplay for him.
Like...
I think if he knew where I was, he could have more ability.
I also don't like this.
I personally do not like this map for arenas in general.
Damn, Doki, do you like anything?
It's just this general area.
Oh, they're over here.
They're gonna come up from that side, maybe.
Jesus Christ.
You okay there, buddy?
Nah, I'm unlucky.
Unlucky here.
Who's next?
Who?
There you go.
All right, who's washed?
Who's washed?
Who's fucking washed out?
Yeah, who's fucking washed out, baby?
That's okay, right?
Got my gun!
Now it's over!
How much money do I have?
All right, fuck it.
You're better.
Oh, dang.
That's right.
That's fucking right, baby.
That's fucking right!
Better be playing against Khoshan, yes.
All right.
Let's see.
Where are I...
I hate...
I'm so bad at this tracker shit!
Okay.
Jesus, no.
Fuck.
I'm just gonna put mine in, too.
Oh, no.
Okay, it's me versus...
There we go.
Let's go!
That's right, Khoshan!
Maybe you're washed!
Oh, sorry.
That was like...
Sorry, that's the adrenaline calling.
You're a good player, Khoshan.
Sorry.
He's a good player.
That's just the adrenaline talking, guys.
That's just the...
Oh, I can't use that anymore.
Okay.
Fuck.
You know what?
If I...
Maybe I could get away with using two guns here.
All right.
If I win this, then I don't have to worry.
That's...
He's back.
That's right.
And to be fair, I am using my best guns, to be fair.
I'm still really bad at this whole tracking shit thing.
Yeah.
Oh, I can break it.
Okay.
That's good to know.
That's actually really good to know.
Oh.
All right.
I don't know...
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I don't know where exactly they're gonna be going towards.
Oh.
I'll make sure I don't get flanked, too.
Are they all this way?
Okay.
I'm just...
I'm getting across throughout my team.
There you go.
Oh, they're gonna res, though.
There's no way they don't res that.
That's a good area to res.
What?
Oh, he got the bat off.
That's unlucky.
Oh, my God.
My teammate got fucking ran at.
That's unlucky.
Sudden death.
No!
I lost all the good guns!
Guys!
I put it all on this!
How could you lose?
What am I gonna do now?
Broke!
Oh, wait.
I'm not broke.
I'm not.
Okay.
All right.
She just played...
What do you mean?
I got the first kill!
I got their best player!
Okay.
No, that's not true.
They have another player that has a 20 bomb.
Am I...
Oh, my God.
I'm like...
How do I...
Jesus Christ!
I'm at 1v3 people with 20 bomb.
You guys still play this game regularly.
I've been on the fucking third-person grind.
Oh, my God.
Sorry.
That's toxic.
I'm...
All I'm saying, I've been on the third-person grind for so long.
How are you guys losing to me in a 1v3 scenario?
That should never be, like...
That is actually embarrassing.
Like...
That is absolutely very embarrassing for you to be losing this.
Oh, my God.
Where?
Guys, please don't get picked.
I beg of you.
I need to reset.
I'm like, not even...
I'm not even, like, buying the right thing.
If I lose this, it's not...
There is no way it's because of me.
I literally clutched this from my team so many times.
Jesus Christ, I can't...
I have not even Bach grenades.
I should have Bach grenades, guys.
I realized that that was my...
That was very dumb of me to not...
To not do?
Alright, let's see.
This guy was one, two...
Fuck!
Jesus Christ, okay.
I wish you told me...
What the fuck?
Just...
Just for the sake of it.
You know, it's toxic, but I take it.
Aw, shoot.
Okay.
I'll full heal.
You know what?
Yeah, I can get this.
Yeah, they're gonna get that res too.
What the fuck?
That's bad for me, actually.
That's actually really bad for me.
Alright.
They got the res off and I didn't.
Let's see, I can look.
It's fine.
Oh my god, this is not fine.
Oh my god.
It's fine.
Fuck.
Aww.
That sucks.
That's not on me, though.
I should have pushed it.
I actually should have pushed it.
Aww.
My god.
I should have pushed that instead of like fucking... I played for the team.
I... I shouldn't have played for the team.
I... I... I had my Marvel reign.
I was Marvel Rivals brain.
But you know what?
I won all my 1v1s against Caution.
Like...
I... I out... I outplayed Caution.
That's all I care about.
Never played for the team.
Oh, I should have just went for a straight on.
Um... Was this a team-based game?
Come on, Doki.
The moment I stopped playing for a team, it was easy.
It was...
I was just like, God damn it, Doki.
Why?
Why did you care?
You shouldn't have cared.
I... I literally... I literally... The two points I got was me 1v3-ing them.
That... That was how we won.
That was like... Playing for the team.
And just say thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Like, I'm sick.
It's actually...
It's so embarrassing for the enemy team to get 1v3 by me.
I have not been playing... Like, I've been... I've been playing Rivals the last two of the three months.
It is embarrassing for them.
Like... Because they have not stopped.
I know they haven't stopped playing Apex.
My Oshii still got it.
Yeah, you're right.
Doki from four years ago would have never played for the team.
It's literally on them that they... That they let me do that.
Sorry.
Caution.
Like, he's... Okay.
He is a good player.
I would say.
But it's embarrassing.
God, bro.
It's embarrassing.
Okay.
You know what?
I have, like, my odds.
Yes!
All right.
You want to see... Okay.
You want to see, like... See me lose every fight?
Let's get on your...
You guys are enjoying your...
You want to see me lose every shot and fight?
Watch this.
I like those odds.
I... Oh my god.
Wait.
No!
It's the defu...
Okay.
This is the fat wingman skin.
My skin didn't transfer...
I forgot to re-requip this.
Because your skins don't...
Your skins transfer over?
But you have to re-equip it.
You have to re-equip your skins.
So, like, that sucks.
Oh, okay.
This is bad.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Oh!
That would have been cool if I hit that.
That...
But I'm not used to aiming with the...
Thick wingman.
The thick wingman is not it.
Alright.
Now I play serious.
Yeah.
Um...
Now I play serious.
Now I got my actual gun.
Now I got...
You know what?
I could buy a grenade.
Fuck you.
I could be broke.
What was that?
I was...
I told you guys!
Ready to see me miss?
Like...
I was very clear with what was gonna happen, guys.
I was incredibly clear.
I was not trickercoding it.
But I said, ready to see me whiff.
I hate it.
But I'm also not used to aiming with the fat wingman.
For those who don't know, the wingman skin is...
There are...
There's pay-to-win apex skins here.
And that was one of them.
Okay.
Is this...
Why?
Sucks for me.
Okay.
Oh, they naded me.
Jesus, that was a good nad.
That was actually a really good nad.
Oh my god, no.
I don't know my keybinds.
I forgot.
I was trying to swap my...
I used my swap...
I used the wrong keybind.
God damn it.
That was my bad.
My...
I have a swap gun keybind on...
But I used my melee instead.
I was gonna swap my gun.
Oh, that would've been like...
So cool if I got that kill.
Yeah.
No, it was just my fault.
I...
Forgot...
Because I have a swap gun keybind.
But...
I like forgot which one was it.
I used my...
I used my melee instead.
So I did this.
Instead of my swap gun.
But you'll see.
You'll see.
You'll see, guys.
Because it's like my mouse buttons.
That's why I accidentally made it.
That's why I just made it.
Alright.
I forgot.
It should give me one automatically, right?
Yeah, see?
So...
I have this.
So you see that?
I swap my gun.
But I did this instead.
Because it was my other mouse button.
I was like, which mouse button is it?
Let's try and find out live.
Okay.
You know what?
Where are they?
Let's see.
I know, like, one guy likes to fucking flank, so...
I'm gonna do it.
There you go.
There he is.
He's a idiot.
Okay.
Why are you guys...
Why?
Why was he playing like that?
Okay, wait.
Yeah, I fucking knew he was there.
I was gonna say, he can...
Alright, I don't have to use that.
Yay!
Alright.
I knew close range, I win that close range.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, now I don't know what to do.
I used all my good guns, guys.
Okay, I guess I could flatline.
I'm not very good at flatline.
This is like, ride or die.
Ride or die!
Alright.
If we lose...
If we win this, yippee.
If we lose this, I already used up all my money.
And then, yeah.
I had to use that.
That ult was really good for my end.
I'm just gonna...
Oh, they're over there.
I should hit him twice.
Yeah.
Whoops.
I hit myself.
Bro, stop ego peeking!
I hear them.
I hear them close by.
No!
There we go.
Hoping I get this out.
No.
They're weak.
They're weak?
Fuck.
They were not weak.
No!
Aw.
They were not weak.
I need this.
Yeah.
I needed a shatter cap there.
His AD strafe was good.
That guy's AD strafe fucked me up.
Okay.
Please contribute.
Team, please contribute.
I...
I saw the dam.
Team, please.
Please contribute.
Team!
Team, please!
Their team had contributions across the board!
Any tips on ADStrape?
It's just be unpredictable.
Okay, if I had the practice range, I could show you guys.
Okay, I can actually.
I can show Narenas.
I can... He's... He's basically playing on your own.
This is Narenas.
Doesn't matter!
Why do I have to pick up the load?
I used all... You're right.
I used all my team gotchas in the first couple of matches.
You're right.
Oh my gosh.
Seven hours.
Narenas left.
Please spare me.
I'm so tired.
Oh my god.
Give me... Give me back my battle royale.
I do keep asking for after me.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Funny story about yesterday.
Someone asked that during the meet and greet.
And then like...
And then like it caught like the entire staff off guard.
And then like the staff came in and was like apologize.
We're so sorry.
Next time we'll make sure we'll cut the mic out if anyone asks questions without our approval.
And then like...
I was like, no, it's okay.
It was pretty funny.
Literally like we're so sorry.
I was like, no, it's funny.
It was funny.
It was cool.
Okay.
Let's see.
I don't know what to do for first.
Oh, wait.
I'm fucking vantaged.
God fucking.
That was not paying attention.
I was not paying attention as to what the fuck I was.
Eh, fuck it.
Let's just rainbow check.
Uh...
Tackle that guy.
That's right.
I'm married to the grind.
It's all about the grind, baby.
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
I forgot.
I'll show you guys how to make an AD strafe.
Unpredictable.
How the fuck?
Okay.
This is stupid.
I... Oh, my God.
I can't believe I'm on echo.
I'm on vantage.
They're like over there.
I saw them.
They're running fucking Gibby.
Bro.
Bro, fucking...
Oh, my God.
This guy is like a pussy.
Right now.
Jesus.
Oh, my God.
You play like a fucking pussy!
Actually cringe.
Holy shit.
Get some mock grenades.
Okay, that was like...
That was Gibby.
I was like, you're on Gibby!
Why?
You have an arm shield!
Why would you possibly be scared?
Oh, Jesus Christ.
Okay.
You're fucking dead.
Oh, my God.
And you're playing lifeline, too.
She is wild.
Bro, they're playing fucking res.
Oh, my God.
All right.
Let me...
Now that I got my shit gun out of the way...
Now...
Suna, thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you!
Oh, my God!
I love my brother.
Suna was the one that did the membership wallpaper.
Uh...
The membership wallpaper.
For April.
Uh...
The barista one.
Oh, my God!
Suna, I just paid...
I paid you!
And you paid me back!
Thank you!
I really appreciate it.
This is what you get when you get too much.
Bro, he has an arm shield!
He did not have to jiggle peek!
And that guy is a fucking pussy!
If I have an...
If you have an arm shield, you get one free fucking shot.
Like...
One free peek!
He was playing so cautious for a Gibraltar.
That's all I'm saying.
Okay.
We...
I did...
Oh, my...
Jesus Christ.
I thought I was...
Guys!
You can tell how I thought...
I thought I was...
Someone else.
You can tell.
Oh, no.
I thought I was a different character, guys.
Alright.
Where are they?
Oh, my God.
Where...
How...
I'm trying to figure out where they are.
Swear to God.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
I'm not getting that stupid fucking res off you lifeline.
I know you are lifeline.
You're not getting that res off.
You're such a...
Bitch, too.
If you're gonna try...
I don't hear him.
I'm taking shots.
So, I can do this.
I went for it because I couldn't hear.
That's fine.
I still have my other teammates.
Who I believe won't be dead weight, right?
Jesus Christ, really?
Don't be dead weight.
Cause I got two.
Oh, my God.
Thank God.
Okay.
I...
I was gonna...
I was gonna be like...
These...
Two of these players...
I know...
Still play as Apex.
I...
I was like...
They got...
Don't...
They did it.
I know.
Two of them...
Still plays Apex.
And still plays in rank.
So, I'm gonna be like...
I swear to God.
I...
Don't be dead weight.
That's all I ask.
Don't be...
You're like pure...
It's your raw aim.
It's good for like...
Aim practice.
But I fucking hate it.
Because like...
People play like...
Pussy sometimes.
Like...
People play...
They don't...
Oh, my God.
They...
I don't know how to explain it.
They just play in such a way...
That makes me mad.
He...
Jesus Christ.
Like...
Get be lifeline.
In arena.
Get be lifeline in arena.
Especially, too.
Bro, I...
Can see you.
You're really gonna use an akimbo.
I swear to god, team.
Jesus Christ, you're not better than me.
Heal yourself three times.
Heal yourself three times and see how it goes.
All right.
Okay, guys, I'm okay.
Sorry.
Sorry, Sue, now that I get to see this.
I'm sorry.
All right, let's see.
Normally, I don't want to run havoc, but...
Okay.
Sit down.
But it's true.
I see Preet is awesome.
So...
Guys, this is why I play support in Rivals.
I would be so fucked up if I placed DPS in Rival Rivals.
I would not be okay.
This is how angry I am.
I can get really angry.
And...
You know what?
I forgot.
I'm not fucking...
I keep thinking I'm... for some reason...
I keep thinking I'm someone else.
Aw.
Oh my god.
I think their goal is just to get me out of the game.
Honestly.
Oh my god.
I can't do this.
Close range.
No.
No!
Fuck!
I thought that covers me.
Oh, I threw.
I thought that was cover.
Oh my god.
I thought I was uncovered.
That sucks.
I'm so sad.
I threw that.
No!
Ah!
Stupid arenas!
Abbing was not it.
No.
I thought they...
They fixed the recoil.
But...
Oh my god.
They got rid of all my favorite guns.
I don't know what to use.
All the guns I usually use is like taken.
So I'm like, what the fuck do I play?
We'll just go all out.
Honestly.
There we go.
Which one is this?
Okay.
It's burst fire.
I just have to figure out if it's burst fire or not.
Oh, I can't.
Okay.
Alright.
My god.
Now I have to use different...
Now I have to use util.
Fucking util.
God damn it.
You fucking suck.
Stupid util.
God damn fucking util tab.
I gotta make sure there's no people crossing us from here.
I hear them.
Actually?
No.
No, I do.
There's people there here.
I hear them, but...
Where?
Okay.
Over there.
This is really...
I'm throwing.
I will admit I'm throwing if our team loses this because of this.
You're dumb.
You're actually dumb.
Oh my god.
You're actually...
Oh, fuck.
He had a Mastiff.
I didn't count on the Mastiff.
God damn it.
Where's my support?
Bro, I swear to god.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna go Joker mode and go Lifeline.
I...
I was throwing.
I didn't say I was throwing.
Oh my god.
I was gonna go Joker mode and I would...
I'm gonna go Lifeline.
That's it.
I'm going Lifeline.
If I can't...
If no one supports me, I support myself.
I have to be the support.
I swear to god.
I'm gonna be the support.
Alright.
Be fair.
My character had like...
My character's abilities was not helpful too.
If no one will support me, I shall support myself.
I shall fight.
I'll do it myself.
Also, let me grab my fucking gun skin.
If I want to do wingman again.
Let's see.
Wingman skins.
Yeah.
It's so weird.
They have like...
Oh wait.
They unlock everything.
Okay.
So...
Which one was it?
I use this...
I use the dismantler.
Oh yeah.
You guys.
You can have access to all your skins.
To ev...
Not all your skins.
To every skin in this game.
Whoa.
Oh wait.
No.
This is my skin.
I use the death ray.
I use this for...
Um...
For my wingman.
Oh my god.
Just...
Oh.
Alright.
I did a dumb...
I...
I did a Hail Mary there.
Um...
But I didn't think he had...
A lifeline drone.
I should've...
I should've knew he was gonna get a lifeline drone there.
But that was actually like...
A...
Hail Mary attempt.
Like...
If it didn't work, we lose.
But if it didn't work, we win.
Cause like...
If I just play with them, then they just collapse...
Around me.
Didn't they change the...
Pay to...
Oh, I should've changed my R9 too.
My R9 flatline needs to be...
The pay to win skins are...
R9 flatline...
Wingman.
And...
I think that's it, right?
And massive.
There's a pay to win massive skin too.
Uh...
All skins are unlocked in early access.
Alright, it's time.
I shall be the suppo...
I will heal myself.
Streamer mode?
Okay, this is a three stack.
What?
There's no way you put yourself in streamer mode.
That's a three stack right there.
I refuse to believe they're not three stacking.
Okay.
I...
There's no way.
Alright, what's this?
I'll use this.
Bow check is my throwaway gun choice.
Okay, so...
This is how you AD's shape.
It's like...
You...
Make sure you go right a little bit too...
It's like...
You gotta be super unpredictable.
And...
Yeah, like...
The thing is, you have to do it unconsciously too.
Like...
It can't be, like, something you, like, think about while you're...
Fighting.
So, like, that's the hardest part.
The hardest part is just the fact that you have to be able to do it...
In a way that's not conscious.
Like, you...
You're not, like, aware...
Oh my god, it's tracking.
Are you serious?
Here we go.
Alright.
I can't give it to him.
Wait.
Oh my god, that was...
Oh no.
I got flanked by three.
That's unlucky for me.
Yeah, that was a bad play by me.
But bow check is my throwaway gun.
Oh, don't make me...
Don't make me put out...
That's it.
I'm bringing it out.
I'm bringing out that gun.
First round is my throwaway round.
You know that.
I...
That's it.
I'm bringing it.
Oh, that's good.
Good play.
Good play by that guy.
I know he's been playing Apex still.
But still, regardless, it's an incredibly good play.
This has...
There's no way a three...
Like, there's no way they found three solos who did streamer mode.
There's no way.
I refuse to believe.
That's what you say.
I know.
I recognize people.
You cannot say that.
I specifically call out the people I recognize.
I know I've been still playing this game.
That's it.
I'm...
I'm going all in.
I...
That's...
Fucking it.
I'm getting my...
My R9.
Why is it replaying this?
I don't remember.
I swear to God.
It was like...
Lifeline Gyppy is like...
Um...
Arena meta?
I swear to God.
I am.
Will we die?
Let's find out.
Whoa.
Oh, they're not even on this side.
Of the map.
That's...
Awkward.
My gores, mata wants, Fiifu.
You never win.
Oh my God.
Is working?
Oh aah.
Jesus.
Are you...
They actually bought...
That's... yeah.
Okay, they are a three stack.
They actually bought Gibeal on round one.
Oh, that's a real arena team.
That's actually a real team.
Oh my god.
I used up all my gacha luck on the first two matches.
Now it's like... now it's an uphill battle.
I should have got two guns.
This was my last... chance.
I could have bought two guns there.
But I didn't.
I refused.
See, look at this.
This guy was not a coward, at least.
You know, I...
At least he wasn't a fucking coward with his arm shield.
Whoever that Gibe player last game was...
Goddamn played like a goddamn bitch.
Jesus.
I can't.
I'm sorry.
Oh, Jesus Christ.
No!
I didn't see him.
He's right here.
Oh, I threw that.
I didn't realize he had a cross on me.
Oh, no.
No!
He had a cross!
Right here.
Oh!
I need to know who are you.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, that's a three stack.
That's a three stack.
No.
I told you.
I do it!
We're three stacking!
I can do it.
Yo, Doki.
You good?
No.
I'm not.
I'm not good.
I...
I'm dodging.
You don't know.
I'm not dodging.
I'm not a pussy.
I'll get RNG.
I'll get a good teammate RNG.
I believe.
I'm not a pussy.
I'm not dodging this.
I...
Jesus.
I wish I had a three stack.
I'm not.
I'm...
I'm not dodging.
I'm not a pussy.
I will eventually get the...
Wait, I thought this guy was at LAN.
Is this guy not at LAN?
How is he here?
Are they like...
Oh, are they like letting people play it?
Oh, maybe.
Maybe.
Cause it's finals.
This...
Oh, maybe they're letting people play it during LAN.
I won't be surprised.
Yeah.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
They might have set up some LAN.
Cause I was like, wait.
How is he here?
Aren't you...
Aren't you supposed to be at LAN?
No, no.
He does like MC for LAN.
We the people.
I always see him MCing and stuff for it.
Oh no, I meant...
He's not in the pro team.
He's in the...
He usually is like one of the staff mem...
Like not staff, but like...
Um...
What's it called?
Like the...
Like the host MC.
For ALGS.
Yes.
So I'm like surprised to see him here.
Alright, guys.
Where's my throwaway gun?
I always have one throwaway gun that I don't care about.
Nemesis?
Nah.
Carbon?
These are like my go-to for like...
Maybe I can...
Clutch it.
Caster.
Yeah.
Usually...
Well, no, he doesn't cast.
No, no, no.
He's like usually like one of the MCs for it.
Cause like he would like...
He doesn't cast.
He just like...
Um...
Helps with MCing stuff.
Oh, Wingman.
I should've picked Wingman.
You're right.
That should've been my throwaway gun.
Oh, fuck.
Nice.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Um...
I'm gonna put my shield up for him.
Use the shield!
He could've...
I don't know.
Usually I have a shield behind it.
I can't do carbine close range.
I didn't think he would push that close.
Ugh.
Alright.
It's fine.
Okay.
Ugh.
Gotta get my fucking...
Gotta get back my inner groove.
What shield?
Oh my...
Well, you can hide behind my knockdown shield and then heal.
I was hoping he would do that.
But he...
I think he egoed.
Egoed.
Pushed it.
Which is understandable.
I need to like play a lot more passive.
Sure.
Alright.
Ugh.
God, it's getting sweatier.
Guys, I miss when the game was less.
I'm gonna go for the flank here.
Here.
Oh my god.
There you go.
No.
Why?
I just wanna thirst it.
Please heal.
Please heal for the...
Oh my god.
He didn't need a heal.
Thank god.
Okay.
I was gonna be like, please heal.
I swear to god.
Alright.
Seeing you with no shields is like stressing me out.
I was like...
Please.
I need you to heal.
That's all.
I...
Don't ask for much.
I don't...
Matt was jumping around with no shields.
And I was like, please.
We're still playing.
Okay.
He had confidence in his...
I was like, oh my god.
Please.
It's my R9 round.
I...
I don't wanna lose my R9 round.
Hey, please.
It sucks.
I played lifeline so I could like, support myself.
But in the end...
In the end, I have to...
Use my things for my teammates.
Doesn't that...
Suck?
Jesus Christ.
I'm not...
Gonna be by myself there.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Please.
There you go.
Are you serious?
I can't see him.
Where did he drop too?
Oh!
Oh my god!
It's them!
It's...
The tap straight...
Oh my god.
The tap straight for that.
The thing is...
I had to pay attention to another player too.
It comes back to support...
Guys...
I'm sad...
Because...
I played lifeline to support myself...
But I had to use my drone for my teammates.
I...
Oh my god.
God damn it.
Every time...
I have to support my team.
When can...
When is it Doki's time?
When is it Doki's time to not care?
I...
She cares too much.
Oh my god.
Stop being supportive.
I can't!
I'm too...
I play too much support.
I can't.
This sucks.
Oh my god.
I swear to god.
No.
Where is he?
There we go.
Stop your stupid fucking tap strafing.
Like...
Stop it.
I'm not a controller player.
Get the fuck out of here with your...
Tap strafe.
Like...
Alright.
Okay.
I did use my teammates as bait.
Like...
I...
I did that so I could...
Use him as bait.
Cause I knew he was gonna thirst him.
I...
I like...
100% knew he was gonna go straight for the thirst.
Umm...
Fuck.
I don't know.
I don't know what gun to play when I'm in this situation.
I don't...
Uh...
Okay.
No.
He's a movement player.
I mean...
Did you see him?
Did you...
I mean...
We all saw that.
He's...
Like...
Yeah.
He is a movement player.
Oh no.
I'm starting to shake.
This is not good.
Ugh.
Fuck.
Okay.
I'm actually shaking now.
My hands.
I hate it when it happens.
Ugh.
I preemptively gave that to him.
Because I don't trust him.
To like...
Not kill himself.
It's more like...
I just don't trust him to stay alive at this point.
That sucks.
Cause I'm actually...
My hands are actually shaking.
Which is not good.
Umm...
See I told...
I fucking...
I don't want...
Well...
Light sucks for him I guess.
There.
I did that again.
Fucking idiot.
Tap strafe more.
You should have known last round I wasn't a controller player.
You should have...
No...
Tap strafe more.
Do it.
I had to deal with time.
Tap strafe more for me.
I...
My goat.
She's warming up.
How come it's not...
How come it's not Battle Royale?
We're stuck in arena jail.
For...
20 more minutes.
We're really...
We're gonna...
move more.
I'll wait...
Like...
Seriously.
Don't be stupid.
Like...
Oh my god.
God...
I don't know.
Baiting people was worth it.
Maybe I should...
I should just use Rez to bait.
I don't know.
20 more minutes.
The goat is here.
With 20 more minutes.
That's my...
That's my Oshii.
Don't worry.
I'll be free in 20 more minutes.
I will be free.
I swear, if I had to play against the... was it Nia?
That was the tap... oh my god.
You look so tired.
Are you okay?
Did you not see the guy just had to fucking fight?
It is... I had three hours of sleep and I started stream at 9 in the morning.
I do not have time to deal with the tapstrapers.
I... I do not have time.
I...
Oh my god.
I am not here for that.
Oh wait.
I'm fighting a dev.
Dev is in here.
Guys, be nice.
I was like...
Bro, I'm not here for this right now.
Like, I'm not here for...
Fucking tapstrapes.
Bro, I'm tired.
I'm so tired.
I...
Alright.
I don't know.
I don't know what gun to use starting off every time.
Oh, hook run carbide.
First round is always the throw away round anyway.
I mean...
We go with he the people...
We the people.
He's number one.
I'm not gonna say what I'm gonna say.
Based off of...
The last arena fight I had.
The last arena fight I had was...
Wait, what the fuck?
What the fuck?
I don't know what you're gonna do.
I don't know.
Okay.
There we go.
Alright.
What was...
What was the...?
It was the mirage fucking resting non-stop.
Like, I'm too tired to find them.
I'm...
I'm too tired to find him.
I'm just like, I can't.
I'll say that the last round, he was Ungabunga.
The last game, I had to go through a catastrophic trauma to clutch it for us.
Let's just say that.
And he still plays this game.
I have moved to rivals, and I had to deal with the shit I had to pull.
The things I had to pull to win us that last game, I... Oh, man.
With the amount of sleep I got... It was not it for me.
It was absolutely not it.
Oh, my God.
I ego-pushed that.
Whoops.
I ego-pushed the hell out of that.
You better fucking support me after I supported you.
Oh, my God.
You better clutch this, people.
Peeps, you better clutch this afterwards.
This is my R9 round.
Okay.
I'm not ego-peaking.
I'm not ego-peaking anymore.
I am.
But at what cost?
Oh, no.
Okay.
Alright.
Now I know.
I'm not ego-peaking.
No.
The one time I won an ego-peak, I had three... I shouldn't have aimed at three people.
They just look so juicy down there, guys.
Like, it was... Like, all... They were all grouped up.
You don't understand.
They were all grouped up.
I was like, ooh, look at that juicy shots I can make right now.
I'll go in this way.
Okay.
No, I did it again.
Oh, my God.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, he's right there!
He was right there!
Jesus.
Okay.
Wait.
Please look around.
Oh, my God.
Thank God.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
He did it.
Okay.
Thank God.
Oh, he did it.
I got heavily pushed there.
Oh, my God.
Oh, thank God.
And, you know, I take back everything I said about last game.
I...
I take it all back.
You're cool, buddy.
You're cool, man.
You're...
Everything I said, I never meant it.
You're pretty cool.
I'll use Nemesis again.
Actually, I can buy...
Oh, I can't.
I don't care about my...
Redemption tour.
Nice.
I'm the thrower now.
I'm playing, like, not a support anymore.
I'm, like...
I'm too...
I'm too up in my head now.
Jesus.
Oh, my God.
I hate U-Till.
I will never like U-Till.
U-Till stupid.
Not one.
I will never like U-Till.
Jesus.
Oh, my God.
Where is he?
Where the fuck is he?
Okay, I'm rezzing.
Okay, I see him.
They might rezz by either guy.
I'm pretty sure.
I didn't thirst him, so they're gonna rezz the other guy.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
That's bad for me.
They definitely rezzed the other guy, though.
I won't be surprised.
Oh, wait.
No, they didn't.
He got full thirsted.
Thank God.
Thank God he got real full thirsted.
That was a good flank.
It's fine.
Ego peeked it.
What's U-Till?
Fucking nades.
Bro, buddy.
Bro.
I hit four teams.
I'm sad.
Oh, the fucking 14.
Oh, the classic Mastiff.
14, 14.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
One more arena, and then we'll be in Battle Royale.
Let's go.
I'm not okay.
All right.
I'm done playing support.
I'm done supporting these fools.
I'm so over it.
All right.
Let's see.
I don't know.
I guess, like...
I don't even know what to play anymore.
I don't know what's meta.
I can't do more damage than...
Yeah, when...
All right.
I'll do Bangalore.
It's been a while.
I don't know if smoke's good, though.
I think, actually, if I can, I want to play Sparrow again.
Um...
Mirage time.
Okay.
That Mirage juice were pretty good.
Not gonna lie.
The Mirage shit they were doing was, like, pretty fucking tilting.
I just haven't seen Mirage in a long time.
Especially in arena.
And then I was just like, where are they?
There's more than one...
Wait, there's supposed to be three people in arena.
Why is there ten?
What's up, baby?
I love you.
Why is there ten people?
All right.
Nice.
Yeah, that's right.
You went getting Sparrow.
That's right.
How can you say it?
Like, I love you?
To...
Oh, wait.
I was gonna say.
I thought he was gonna take Ash from him.
I was like...
He was like, bro, I love you.
And then he was gonna take his character.
Lock in Spider-Man.
And as they give us a super chat, thank you, thanks.
It's okay.
Peeps...
Peeps redeemed himself.
Oh, shit!
It's another dev!
Oh my god!
All right, dev.
Oh!
Okay, it's okay.
That's fine.
Is Mirage meta now?
I think so.
I don't know.
You know what?
My throwaway round.
Let's go.
It's my throwaway round.
I have...
Let's fuck it.
I need the iron sight.
I don't know what to do about it.
Let's go!
It's my throwaway round.
Woo!
Yippee!
And then I can have Battle Royale.
All right.
Give us that.
I have the bow check.
Oh my gosh.
I wish I could use bow check more, but it's so bad at arena.
I just...
Like, I think, like...
Because everybody plays such close quarters for arenas that, like, there's no reason to...
See streamer mode?
I know they're streamers.
Nice.
Jesus Christ, of course.
Oh my God.
What the fucking...
What did he have?
It was so fast.
Oh my God.
I swear to God.
If you start tap-shrieving, I swear to fucking God.
I...
I swear to God.
If I see that man tap-shrieving, I swear...
I was gonna freak out.
I...
You tap straight one more time.
And do that dumbass...
Okay, look.
It's cool.
I...
I swear to God.
Truly stuck in arena hell.
I...
I'm not a big fan of arena.
I don't know if you guys noticed that.
I...
I just like Battle Royale.
Get me out of this...
It's getting me out of this prison.
Get me out...
I just...
I just wanna...
I just wanna shoot.
I can't...
I don't know.
Wouldn't be funny if...
Wait.
Is Peeps gonna be okay?
Where are they?
Bro, what the fuck?
Peeps?
Let's go.
Yep, fuck it.
Alright.
Oh my God.
I swear...
I swear to God.
I saw that move and shit!
I was like, I'm going in.
I'm putting you down.
Get down!
I don't want this shit in my lobby.
I...
See what happens.
The moment I saw one little bit of movement, it's over.
I'm coming in.
I mean...
No movement in this lobby.
No movement allowed.
I can't...
I won't...
I won't stand for it.
I...
He was gearing up.
Alright.
Oh, is that Fade?
That's right, Fade.
This is a no movement zone.
I...
I knew it.
I could tell.
It's like, it's one of you guys.
It's one of you movement streamers.
I could tell.
I could smell it.
I smell the movement in you.
Jesus.
Just us two.
Oh my god.
And they went Gibby too.
Gear them to my left.
Jesus Christ.
I'm dead.
Jesus.
They're all doing it.
And I have no cover.
I had no cover.
I was stuck here.
I was stuck.
It's okay.
I have my ult here.
It's alright.
Oh my god.
That's because he just goes in.
With no backup.
But like, we're against like, players who like, can hold their own.
So much movement.
Let me think.
Okay, obviously.
I'll take the massive.
The only way to put down a movement player.
The only way I know how.
The only way.
The only way I know how to do.
It's unfortunately true.
These guys are good.
I mean, they're all.
They're all.
Oh, they are asking me.
Cast it.
Oh.
That's not fuck.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Keeps gonna get run at.
Unless.
I hear the res.
Oh my god.
Fuck.
Okay, I'm gonna get pushed.
Nope.
Nice.
He got.
We win.
Wait.
We don't win?
The only way I know how.
This is how you get rid of a movement player.
Massive is the only way.
Goodbye movement.
Goodbye.
That's my goat.
All right.
It's almost time.
I'm going.
I'm waiting.
I can wait.
I'm not doing another arena.
I can.
I'm down to wait.
The next three minutes.
Strength versus dexterity.
Goodbye movement.
We're free.
I want to know who the fuck was that guy that was trying to tapstrap everywhere in front of me.
Was that also Fade?
I do not.
There was no way that was also Fade.
I wish I like looked at who it was.
Oh man.
I wish I looked at who the fuck that guy was that was doing that fucking bullshit on me.
I had to.
Was that also Fade?
That game where he was doing like one million fucking jumps on me and then I just like tracked him with my shotgun and then he died.
Who was that guy?
Does anyone...
Wait.
Oh, the last game.
No, I'm not talking about this game that we just had.
I'm talking about the game where I put down another movement player with a shotgun.
That guy.
I need to know who the fuck that guy was.
Because that guy.
Oh my god.
That guy is living rent free in my head right now.
He did his job.
He wanted people...
He wanted to have clip moments and he's living rent free in my mind.
Even though I won.
I won, but I'm still thinking about him.
I'm still...
That shit was bullshit.
That shit I had to deal with.
Alright.
That's a movement player's victory.
Yeah.
He won...
He won the mental warfare against me.
Yeah.
He did.
I mean, that's all.
He got his...
He got...
I won, but...
I'm still thinking about it.
I...
The psycho...
You never win a psychological battle against movement.
You never do.
You're always thinking about it.
Oh, man.
I'm not...
I'm too tired to tap straight.
I'm too tired.
I'm literally just...
I'm fucking getting by with just aim.
He won...
You won the battle.
He won the war.
Literally...
Literally, aim is taking me to the finish line right now.
Your fingers there.
No, I...
I'm just going...
Going by by pure aim.
I'm not doing anything fancy.
Which is very embarrassing for some of the teams I played against today.
I don't know.
I don't know about you guys.
But I had...
I played against some players who might have been playing this game non-stop and haven't stopped like me.
And they still got 1v3'd.
I don't know about you.
Come on.
8 players?
Guys!
They said 11 a.m.
Get your ass in my battle royale.
11...
Get in here!
There's no way!
It says 11 to 1.
It's battle royale.
I swear to God.
If I...
There's no way I missed the battle royale queue.
I refuse to believe I missed the battle royale queue.
There is no way!
They just really, really love arenas, Doki.
Can you really blame them?
I swear to God.
I'm looking at other people's streams and some of them had 22...
Is it West Coast?
Is the...
I swear to God.
If I swap...
Why are they moving up?
Oh my God.
I'm going to...
I swear to God.
Third law.
Oh my God.
I swear.
I'm going East.
I'm going East Coast.
Right now.
There's no way.
No, I can't even...
Oh my God.
There's no way.
Okay.
U.S.
East.
I'm opening up someone else's stream.
And then they had 28 players in queue.
I am...
I am mad.
They have 35 players in their lobby.
This is not fair.
This is discrimination against me.
Alright.
There's no way.
Tell me how many players.
How many...
How many players?
Tell me.
I need to know.
Please.
Tell me.
Nine players?
Where did they all go?
What lobby am I in?
How did they get less players?
Oh my God.
I swear.
Okay.
I swear to God.
Maybe...
Maybe they're in U.S.
East 1.
They went back to West Coast.
They went...
There's no way.
Where's my queue?
Where's my lobby?
There...
I'm looking at another person's streamer.
Start like with another person's POV.
And it's going up.
I don't understand.
How is that possible?
How...
Oh my God.
Am I locked?
Did they lock me in West Coast?
I'm sad.
I'm so sad.
He looks like...
No.
Don't do this to me.
How...
How do they have 39 players in queue and I have 12?
How?
They can't do this to me.
This is all I wanted.
We haven't...
Done enough arena matches yet.
The West Coast Prison.
No.
Please.
Let me be involved.
I want to be involved.
I traveled to East Coast for you.
Let me be involved.
Please.
Do you know how much I sacrificed?
I played two hours of arena.
This is all I want.
They can't do this to me.
I'm going to crush up.
Oh my God.
It went down.
It actually went down.
There's no way.
There's no fucking way.
Oh my God.
It's because they got moved.
They got chosen to be in the other lobby.
That's not fair.
Because the other lobby could...
Oh my God.
The other lobby.
The other lobby got a game.
And they chose people from my queue to be...
To go into the other lobby.
I was not chosen.
I can't get the shit down.
Chat are we cooked.
So thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I was not chosen.
They didn't...
I'm going back to my homeland.
And I'm going back.
Oh my God.
They didn't pick me.
It's okay.
I'm okay.
The only thing I wish is that...
I wish that you can...
You can like...
Um...
Do something else.
While you're in queue.
That is the one thing I would like to have changed.
To don't keep complaining too much about arenas.
So now they are punishing her.
Don't.
Please.
I didn't mean it.
Oh my God.
I swear to God.
Just one Battle Royale game.
Just...
One Battle Royale game.
That's...
All I ask.
Please.
I...
I don't ask for much.
I don't ask.
I just want...
One game.
Please.
I...
I went...
Are you not entertained?
Respawn.
I went through your...
Your arena jail.
I...
I went through it all.
I went through three different movement players.
I...
And I put them down with my shotgun.
That's it.
I'm pulling up bloons.
We have to reinstall...
Sorry.
I uninstalled bloons, guys.
I need...
Guys.
Give me a second.
Let me reinstall bloons real quick.
And we might start buffering a little bit.
Because I'm installing bloons.
We have nine players in queue.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
Why am I still uninstalled?
Because I needed space for...
I needed space for early access.
So, I was uninstalling everything I have.
It was 80 gigabytes.
Okay.
The early access file.
All right.
We're the...
We have nine players.
Oh, my God.
I'm gonna freak out right now.
All right.
Let's see.
Yay.
Let me figure out where it was.
Is it gaming?
All right.
Let's see.
Just so you can see.
You still see it.
How many people are still in queue, at least.
You know?
You still see that?
Just put it right...
Right here.
So you still see that I am...
Did it go...
I'm the fifth player?
How?
There's something wrong.
There has to...
I'm looking at support center.
Oh, wait.
Guys, wait.
I'm restarting my game.
There is no way there's five players in queue.
There is no fucking way.
I...
Okay.
Give me a...
Guys.
No.
Give me a sec.
I'm restarting my game.
There's no way.
There's only five players.
How am I not get...
How did it go down?
How did it...
I'm restarting my game.
Stop the comm restarting.
Just in case.
Just in case, guys.
You're in losers queue.
You...
There's no way.
Why would they leave?
Why...
They said...
They said 11am.
We can battle royale.
They can't do this to me!
I played their games!
I was a good bird!
I woke up at 9am for you!
I did everything right!
Yeah, it was PSC because...
I didn't even... Okay.
There we go.
Please.
I've been a good boy.
I've been... I've been a good boy.
That's all I want.
Okay.
Back to Bloons, by the way.
Alright.
So we know that... Alright.
I do!
I have to restart!
Oh my god!
Alright!
I have to... Oh my god!
I'm... I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Let's still play Bloons.
Alright.
Okay.
I have to restart.
I have to fucking restart.
Who would've thought?
Oh my god.
Alright.
If I knew... If I do, I have to restart.
I don't know why I keep going.
I'm sorry.
I don't know why I keep doing Ice Monk.
First.
It's just in my nature.
Just a little banana break.
Guys.
Yippee!
I can afford another monkey.
I just want... Oh wait.
Let's do a Boomerang.
Right here.
And then we can do another Ice Monkey.
Oh no!
Wait.
No, it's fine.
Man.
I believe.
Oh no!
Nice.
Okay.
I've always believed.
I've always believed in you.
Oh!
This is a little... Okay.
Okay, I've always believed in you.
It's okay.
We have this guy for the camo.
There we go.
I always believe.
It's okay, I always believe.
Oh my god, I'm in!
Okay, let's just...
What the fuck?
I'm... My team is... Did I just see my team at the bottom of the... There's no way that my team was at the bottom, skill-wise, of the build curve!
I... I'm scared.
I saw... I was at the very bottom of the build curve!
I'm concerned now.
I literally looked down, and I was like, wait a minute.
Where am I on the bell curve for the team?
That's... That's not good news.
Yeah, but this is a team average.
Like, who is... There's no way I'm pulling down the team.
There... I think... How am I pulling down the team average?
Alright.
I'm... Okay.
SPMM is always right.
Follow the leader!
I don't have any sense of straighter to my... Bro!
Did you... I waited so long to play!
You can't... Oh my god!
Bro!
I waited so long!
Oh my god...
Waaaay!
I waited so long!
Jesus Christ...
Okay.
Cool.
Fuck.
omg.
I got hooked.
I'm so sad.
Why did you do this to me?
Oh my god!
I got Prezi's duo stack too!
Why did you do this to me?
I don't... Oh my god.
I got... This is two different teams, by the way.
This was a different team from Dre's team.
I got Prezi shooting at me from the side, and then Dre shooting at me from the different side, because it's two... This is a different team right there.
Oh my god.
Why did you do this to me?
Why did my team do this to me?
Why did he take us to health?
We're back to the Blues.
He took us to like two different squads.
Alright.
Nice monkey time.
You know, I was expecting people to like... I don't know.
I wasn't expecting there to be where I had to land.
But that's okay.
Oh yeah.
Let me move this now.
Now... Now we just gotta look at here.
Time for Ice Monkey again.
Alright.
We gotta do this again.
Oh wait.
We're over... Oh wait.
Uh... Yeah.
Yeah.
Continue this.
There we go.
It's time.
Bottom of the Belker for a reason.
It was out of my hands.
I couldn't do anything.
It took me to get put down.
I got put down out of... Not out of my choice.
Alright.
In this Ice Monkey time.
Monkey.
Finally.
You could've... Yeah.
With my P20.
Single P20.
Let's go.
Alright.
Ice Monkey.
I'll save up for Gwendolyn later.
Monkey.
The more you use the Monkey.
The more upgrades you will unlock using it.
Monkey.
That's okay.
I just need to get Gwendolyn.
There we go.
Alright.
Monkey.
Now it's upgrade Monkey time.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Wait.
How do I pause?
Okay.
That's fine.
I'm just gonna put... I... I... I... I know I'm gonna be back in this... In this anyway.
Alright.
Guys.
I don't know what I am on the Belker.
I... I don't know.
I don't know.
You got it.
Guys.
I've been through a lot.
But we're in it now.
We're in it.
Remember.
Eyes on the prize.
Alright.
My frames is... Ooh.
It's at 144.
That's alright.
Alright.
I'm okay now.
Guys.
I won't crash out.
I swear.
Dead inside.
That's me.
Oh my god.
That's my other self.
That's playing the game right now.
I have my... That's my other PC.
That has the game on.
Good luck.
I'm okay.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh.
I'll grab that.
Just in case.
Oh.
Let's grab this.
Let me see if I can find an energy... Oh.
I forgot I'm a Sparrow.
See if I can find a... Find a energy gun.
God damn it.
I don't need this.
Oh.
Fuck.
I don't want any of these.
This sucks.
I don't have the guns I actually really want.
I have to...
make sure.
This is just like... Um.
Ash.
Where I don't... Bhop.
Too much.
Cause like... Is Eva 8 or Mastiff better?
People still play... Apex.
People still play Apex.
Have they... Have they improved or un... Improved?
Uh... Eva 8 now?
Okay.
Eva 8 is still better.
That's good to know.
Alright.
Is this guy AFK?
There's no way you're AFK.
There's no... Oh.
Oh.
I was gonna throw him.
Ha ha ha ha.
I was gonna throw him into the lava pit.
To punish him.
Alright.
Ha ha ha ha.
I was ready to punish this man.
For being AFK.
No.
Get an additional.
Oh.
I didn't even rework.
Throwing the speed boost when running towards A mark.
Get additional tackle.
Oh.
Wait.
This was something I was not reading.
Oh.
That's 3 charges that fire fewer pulses in a smaller radius.
Sparell's help will recover if animals are damaged by his ultimate.
Mmm.
I read I have 3 charges.
3 charges is strong.
Yeah.
But I don't have a gold gun that I want to use.
So I can't do anything yet.
Oh.
I have a no attachment.
No attachment.
Carbide.
That's my favorite part.
Don't you guys love it when your thing has no attachments?
I want to get that gun so bad.
But training here doesn't give a fuck.
Wait.
I think I can still... Oh.
I hate no attachments.
Alright.
I'm getting this package.
Sorry.
Sorry Trini.
This is more important.
I'm a loot goblin.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Boy.
My pathfinder is so far.
I'm dead.
No.
My pathfinder was way too far.
My... Wait.
I thought he was behind me.
Oh.
He ran.
Oh my god.
I didn't realize my pathfinder wasn't playing with me.
I was like... I still get my upgraded shields now.
What?
What are you doing?
Are you a... I... Wait.
Just craft us.
Bro.
You can craft us.
What is he?
Oh my god.
Are you new?
I'm at the bottom of the belt.
I'm at the belt curve.
I'm at the bottom of the belt curve.
There's no way.
This is how this man plays.
I'm not even watching this.
I'd be too mad.
I'd honestly be way too mad.
I'm gonna play flutes.
I need to calm down.
I... I need to calm down.
Alright.
Okay.
I don't wanna... Guys, no, you don't understand.
I do not wanna watch this right now.
I don't wanna watch him do whatever the fuck he's doing.
This is fine.
I am fine with that.
Red heart, hot range.
Wait.
Oh, shit.
There we go.
Okay, I should have enough for...
How much do I need?
Wait, I'm back.
Oh, shit.
I'm back.
Shit.
Okay.
I got my stupid ass.
You're back.
I'm alive.
It's like I never die.
It's like...
Oh, my God.
He actually did it.
No, you don't understand.
If I had to watch this guy play after what I just saw...
I'm trying not to crash out.
I'm actually trying so hard not to freak out.
I had... I had to play Bloons to calm down.
You don't understand.
I... I... I would not be okay if like... I had to keep watching him.
I...
I... I definitely would not be okay.
I was doing my best to be a good person.
All right.
New kill leader?
Huh.
I don't know.
Sounds like too much pressure for them.
Replicator incoming, friends.
Me on the coughing...
I'm so sad.
I had such a nice longbow.
I wanted to go...
Pew pew.
I have zero attachments for this.
It's actually crazy.
Oh, I just realized I...
I lost my...
Um...
Gold energy mag that I was holding.
God dammit.
No.
Oh, I'm going there.
I still don't... I don't really need to go.
Oh!
No, I...
I mean like...
I still haven't found...
Oh, wait.
Welcome back.
I still haven't found any attachments that I need.
While I was looting.
That's what I mean.
Not like...
Oh, man.
Why don't I spawn with it?
Not like that.
But like more so like...
I can't be...
Oh my god.
Okay.
I know I just...
Swap guns.
But like...
I rather have a nemesis on my hands.
In a flat line.
Oh, is this like...
Play for yourself?
Oh, man.
Just like how...
I remember Apex.
Just like how I remember it.
Goodbye, Trini.
Goodbye.
My good old...
My good old Apex.
Some things never change.
I hate putting an iron sight.
I hate putting a scope on my...
Where is she going?
Sounds like too much pressure for you.
I'm so confused.
Where...
What do you wanna do, buddy?
Do you care about us?
Are we like...
Nope.
Do you...
Do you want us to be near you?
Like...
I'm...
I'm confused.
Trini...
Do you want us there?
Or do you not want us with you?
I'm so confused.
She's...
She's just gone.
Like...
Trini...
I...
Yeah, there's an enemy?
You know where we are?
Not with you!
Like...
Trini...
Oh, now you're running?
Okay!
Break up your mind!
This is why I'm on the bottom of the bell curve.
This is...
This feels like bottom of the bell curve right now.
They are moving like a goddamn unit.
And then...
This sucks because they have high ground up here.
Are you okay?
Okay.
Oh, there they are.
I'll take that.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, and this guy.
Oh my god.
Are you s...
Oh my god!
I...
At least I kill a praise.
I don't...
I don't know what my team was doing.
I...
I don't...
I don't know what my team was doing.
I...
I literally...
That's a 1v3 that...
I...
Oh my god!
I look so lost!
Oh, I forgot my streamer mode.
Aw, all those cool plays I did.
They don't know it was me.
And they'll never know.
It was me.
Doki.
I'll take it off.
Okay, I'll take off streamer mode.
Uh...
There you go.
Yeah, you look tired.
Um...
With what I just had to do...
With the team I had...
I...
There's a reason why I was tired.
It's okay.
I'm in my safe place now.
I...
I'm sorry, Doki.
It was me.
Oh, man.
Alright.
It's fine.
Oh, I have enough for a helicopter.
It's time.
Boom, boom.
There you go.
Which one was...
Camo?
I forgot.
I don't remember which one was Camo.
Which one goes to Camo?
Second or third?
Guys, second or third?
Back to the middle?
Okay.
There we go.
Back to my happy place.
Where...
Nothing bad can happen to me.
Nothing bad will happen to me here.
Alright.
Here we go.
Enhance freeze.
There you go.
It's fine.
We still have time.
We still have time, guys.
It's okay.
We have so much time.
I believe.
Wait.
Do I get to play Sparrow?
I do not get to play Sparrow.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Wait.
I'll play Conduit.
Alright.
That's fine.
Back to my happy place.
Alright.
This is okay.
I can buy another helicopter.
And then...
Come on.
425.
Alright.
That's fine.
Okay.
I'm happy.
Oh shit.
Okay.
I...
I don't know.
Who are these people in my team?
I...
I don't know who these people are anymore.
I'm so...
I'm like...
I don't know anyone anymore.
I...
I don't know.
My heart of touch, guys!
Guys, I think...
From that last game I had to go through.
Anyone would be in my situation.
Anyone would...
Would react the way I did.
When I...
What...
I had to go through there.
When I saw my Pathfinder fucking run.
When... In the first sight of trouble... When there was like... When I knocked one person down... Anyone will react that.
Like that.
Top 5 reasonable... It's only a natural reaction to the hell I was given.
Okay.
Alright.
I think it's also cause like... Dango.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
A lot of them really good players are also like 3 stacking too.
Or duo or 3 stacking.
So like it makes it harder for me.
Since my poor... Oh my god.
Why are you over here?
Why are you so far?
Are you okay?
I'm always scared going here.
As a solo.
I just don't trust my team.
I have trust issues in this game.
Anyone would.
Honestly.
Anyone would have trust issues.
If you don't have trust issues... You have been stacking for way too long.
You have lived your life... Stacking.
I trust them.
They will come and come.
Clutch.
Where are they?
It's already a res?
What the fuck?
These guys are gonna... Checking... What?
Okay.
My guy wants to fight that.
But there's a guy... There's a team to our right though.
So I'm like... Really?
Are you sure?
Okay.
I only got the Gibby.
I couldn't get the... Oh my god.
He's movementing.
I couldn't.
I don't have Q.
I'm gonna... Oh.
Demo.
Nice.
Alright.
These guys.
I don't know who they are.
I must be... I am definitely not...
with it.
With the times of like... The current... Content Creators.
But they know what they're doing.
And that's... Alright.
By my hands.
Healing.
They knew what they were doing guys.
And at that point... Like... I take that.
I don't know who they are.
But they are good players.
They can fight.
Oh my god.
From what I just went through before... At least they can fight.
I don't ask for much.
A great team in my solos.
I meant like... content... Apex Content Creators.
Cause I don't... Or players.
I don't recognize any of them.
So like... Oh, I don't wanna... Actually?
Fuck it.
Let's go.
This might be bad.
This might be very bad.
I'm not good at 3x though.
Alright.
I don't recognize him.
Is it OX5?
And they are EU.
Never seen him before.
In my lobbies.
To be fair, I haven't played rank in a while though.
If it's EU, then I'm like... Oh, okay.
I mean, it's just one sliver of health.
It's just one sliver of health.
Woo!
No, it's not as good as people think it is.
I don't know.
I personally don't think it's like that great.
It feels like the same old...
Same old, same old type...
Oh wait, I need that.
Uh...
That's too far.
Wait, I need this.
Yeah, I don't recognize him.
So I was like...
Who?
I need bats.
Did I get that right?
Wait, can I...
Oh, I can enhance but we'll check.
Nice.
Oh.
There he is.
I mean, he seems...
He's good.
I'm happy that he's good.
Finally, I'm past the bell curve, guys.
I finally did it.
I'm so happy to see you at this time.
Tired girl.
Yasmin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm glad...
I'm glad you guys are happy to see me too.
Alright.
We have beat the bell curve.
We finally did it.
After the last two teams we've done...
The...
The game has decided to give me my one.
If we could find the players.
I'm gonna say that and then we're gonna get like...
1, 2, 3'd by a whole fucking team.
Oh.
They're fighting.
They're fighting in zone.
I don't wanna deal with that.
Really.
Cause I don't...
Oh, he's right there.
Oh.
That was a huge crack though.
Not gonna lie.
You should push that.
Nice.
I literally naded all of them there.
Yay.
I saw them.
I mean, they were stupid.
They literally opened the door.
To my nade.
That's on them.
Honestly.
That was actually on them.
Alright.
Yippee.
That was like...
Open that door.
They're like, okay.
I mean, I'll take it.
Oh.
What did he dib?
I don't know what he dibbed.
I'll take that then.
I was like, what did he dib?
Should I be polite?
I don't know.
Why?
No, I'm not talking.
I don't have push to talk bind.
Because like...
I never talk to randoms.
If I talk to randoms, all they'll do is disappoint me.
But like, you know, sometimes I get the rare chance that they don't disappoint me.
You know?
Sometimes they...
They don't.
And it makes me like, a little happier in life.
But like...
That's not enough for me to unbind...
To rebind my push to talk.
That's...
If I give them a bit of attention, all they do is just gonna make me sad.
All I'm saying is that...
I will not...
Like...
Even if it was the 1% where I don't get sad...
It's too much effort for just one guy.
Wait, maybe I can swap my bow check.
Oh, it doesn't.
It's still 40.
I thought I was being really clever.
Where like...
I swap my bow check for maybe more ammo.
But like...
I wasn't being clever.
Ha ha ha ha.
Well...
Where?
I don't...
I don't see them.
Oh my god, they're all like...
Jesus Christ, I have to go down.
I'm waiting.
I'm gonna nade this after this is down.
Just in case.
I see them.
Oh.
Coming up.
Where are they?
I'm like so confused as to where they are.
Jesus.
I was like, where are they?
Okay.
I got so confused.
Yeah, reveal my position.
I don't fucking care.
Ha ha ha ha.
Oh my god, I'm lagging here.
There you go, he's in.
Oh my...
Guys, I might have to close bloons.
Ha ha ha.
I might have to close bloons.
I'm...
My frames are dropping.
I...
Ha ha ha ha.
I don't know if you saw that.
But...
Ha ha ha.
I think it was not a good idea to have two games open.
Oh my god.
Oh, that frame drop.
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
Not a good time for me, guys.
There's this.
I hate...
Guys, give me a sec.
Let me close the bloons.
Oh my...
Did you guys see the...
Did you guys see the frame drop?
Ha ha ha ha.
I was like, whoops.
Wait, close A.
Just close Apex Toki.
Ha ha ha.
I was like, wait.
This doesn't look too good.
What is he doing?
Here.
Demo, you don't have to do that.
Just here.
Okay.
Ugh.
Put this on just in case.
Oh no.
What's gonna be there?
You betrayed ice.
Oh my god.
Please don't look.
Jesus, guys.
I can't hit.
Bro check right now.
Oh my god.
I can't.
No!
There's too many.
Guys, don't look.
Don't look.
I can't phone check right now.
No!
I can't.
Ha ha ha ha.
The fuck?
All the FBS gain for this.
Oh my god.
I'm fucking washed.
I can't phone check.
I waited so long just to not be able to phone check.
I should have left bloons on.
I shouldn't use...
Oh, it's Olympus.
I'm gonna use the bathroom real quick, guys.
I'll be right back.
I hit my vault shots from 50 miles away.
And then I can't hit a bow check shot.
What happened to me?
I'll be right back.
I'll use the bathroom though.
Guys.
No more bow check.
Ha ha.
Unless...
Unless it was the scope.
I'm gonna start coping.
It's the scope, guys.
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
It's because of the scope, guys.
No, you don't understand.
I'm not used to 2x on the bow check.
I'm gonna start coping.
Ha ha ha.
It will be...
It will be different next time.
It will be different.
Ha ha ha.
It's fine.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna put...
I'm gonna get a bow check again.
And then...
And I'm gonna...
I'm gonna put no scope on the bow check.
And then I'm gonna hit every shot.
Trust me.
I'm...
I'm just gonna start coping.
Um...
Ha ha ha ha.
It's...
It's how...
That's it.
It's never me.
That's right.
Open a pack.
You're right.
If I open...
These packs don't transfer over, by the way.
You guys know that.
These packs don't transfer over.
I'm opening them.
I literally have everything.
Wait, I have every skin unlocked, too.
Like, I just realized I should have every skin unlocked because it's an early access account.
Wait, do I?
Yeah, I was like, wait a minute.
I don't even need to open packs.
What are you talking about?
I never even needed to open them.
All right, what am I?
There's me on the bell.
Oh my god, no!
It's you!
I'm sorry.
I can't.
I legitimately cannot play with that guy again.
I...
I'm sorry.
I actually cannot play with that guy again.
I...
I would not...
I would not make it.
I...
It's the Pathfinder.
I cannot play with that Pathfinder again.
I...
There's a line on that bell curve that you should not cry for.
I don't think...
I don't think he has enough time to learn.
I don't think he has enough time.
All right, guys.
I'm sorry, but...
No, if you were watching that game...
If you were watching that game where he showed up...
I...
I just...
You don't understand.
I'm...
I'm just not strong enough.
I'm sorry.
I'm not strong enough for that.
I wish I was.
But sadly, I'm not.
We don't...
You'll understand.
No, you'll understand.
He was...
He was playing his own game.
Let me say.
He was...
He was playing his own game there.
He was not playing with us.
He was simply in his own little world.
It's okay.
We can wait.
I am willing to wait.
It's okay.
My team is doing it.
And I've always believed.
Oh my god.
Okay, you know how like...
Okay, before we go... Okay, what about...
Okay, we're getting rid of you.
And we're getting rid of you.
And then we're getting rid of you.
What if...
What if it was just all...
What if we can do this?
Surely this is not a bad idea.
Surely...
Surely this isn't a bad idea, guys.
Surely it isn't.
As long as we keep believing...
It will work.
Okay.
Oh shit, it's fine.
Wait, can I play...
It's fine.
Wait, can I play Sparrow?
Wait, let me see if I can play Sparrow.
Oh, I...
Oh.
Come on.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Alright.
See, I told you.
It's fine.
And then I'll give him a little hat too.
Yay.
Alright.
Nice.
And then what if...
Oh my god, please.
Okay.
I'm sorry, Bloons.
I'm sorry.
I need frames.
Alright.
It's not him.
I didn't see the bell curve.
So we'll never know how disappointed I should be.
I...
We'll never know.
Alright.
That's fine.
Enough lining around.
We dropping.
Guys, don't say that, please.
I don't...
Maybe the bell curve wasn't that bad.
Maybe it wasn't all that bad, guys.
It could be...
We could have hope.
Are you serious?
I...
I just...
Oh my god.
They have nades.
They have nades already.
Go through movement plays right off the bat.
I...
What the fuck?
Yeah, I guess.
The server shut down.
Okay.
It's fine.
Did it lose?
I stopped my bloons for this?
What the fuck?
I don't know who you are.
Bro.
I...
I guess we go back to bloons.
Yeah.
I guess we go back.
Never punish!
It never happened because the server shut down.
It's fine.
Alright.
Back where...
Back where we started.
Will I ever cross the bell curve?
Find out next time on Dragon Ball Z.
Alright.
And then we'll put them here.
And then...
Large.
And freeze for longer.
That's fine.
Do I get Sparrow?
Oh my god!
I don't even...
I forgot to select Sparrow!
That's fine.
Cold snaps.
Wait.
I can do this.
Alright.
Nice.
Guys.
I might lose this.
Because I went with...
I might have fucked up.
Guys.
Ice Monkey's Trout was not it.
Ice Monkey's Trout was not...
Oh wait.
You guys can't see the bloons.
No.
You didn't.
I won.
Guys.
I won the game.
I won my bloons games.
I fucked up.
Because I did too well.
It's actually crazy.
I wish you were there.
Guys.
I just did.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Let me shield self first.
Let me...
Okay.
Alright.
Shot him in the back.
As he deserved.
Bro, this guy's an R9.
That's not fair.
I'm not fucking pushing this.
I'm fucking...
Taking my time.
Third party?
Huh?
Oh man.
Oh.
That's unlucky.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Third party.
Let's go.
Okay.
That was my one bullet, by the way.
That was my...
That was my one bullet.
Let's go.
My one bullet and drink.
I know.
Don't worry about Ring Fry.
We're in the next ring.
Wait.
Hello.
My one bullet.
I missed.
Oh my god.
What?
Okay.
I can't.
Get me out of the bell curve.
I didn't use my shield.
I didn't press Q.
Get me out.
I feel like I did so much, too.
That was the worst part.
I'm going through the five stages of Apex grief right now.
Oh my god.
Thank god.
He died.
They took me to, like, all I'm saying.
Okay.
So this might... This is not a hot take.
But, like, if you're...
If you're gonna take me to hell, you have to play like you can survive hell.
And all I'm saying were these two players did not play like they could survive hell.
If you're gonna take me to six teams... You better play like you can take on six teams.
I... You have... It's not a hot take.
That's all I'm... Don't put me in fucking hell if you can't survive it.
If I had to fucking do four knocks.
If I had to do that much damage within two minutes, by the way.
In two minutes.
And I did three knocks and a kill.
I... You gotta be able to survive this area.
If I had to leave.
You just...
Couldn't handle the heat.
Right.
It's a perfect all constant.
Both three... Damage combined times seven.
That's just...
Am I asking too much?
No, right.
Surely I'm not asking too much, right guys?
Surely that's not it.
She is cracked, but she is only one little bird.
Bro's could not survive the salty split, dude.
No, right?
No, there's no way.
It's not asking too much.
That's like asking the bare minimum.
I'm just... and I think I had the worst position out of every... on my entire team.
I literally landed into a full team.
And I somehow lived longer.
I somehow lived longer than my team.
And I landed in front of someone.
Common and matchmaking in my battle royale.
You're asking too much for a bottom of the curve, teammates.
Surely I'll... oh, I'm slowly... guys, I'm slowly moving up the bell curve.
It's like I'm syphilis... what was his name?
I almost said syphilis.
Oh my god, I'm slowly moving up, guys.
I'm pushing the rock up, guys.
I'm... I'm pushing...
I'm pushing the rock up the fucking mountain.
What's this?
Syphilis?
I don't fucking know how to pronounce his name.
Syphilis.
I'm going up.
Look at that!
The rock is pushing it up!
I am...
How do you pronounce that?
Syphilis.
Keep pushing.
Okay.
Syphilis.
By 30 games, surely I'll be at the middle of this bell curve.
Um...
I believe...
I'm slowly pushing that rock up the curve.
Ah yes, my favorite Greek tragedy is syphilis.
Hahaha.
No, I do need sleep.
I'm like, delirious right now.
I'm...
But at least you guys are enjoying your time.
Alright.
How much did I sleep?
Three hours.
Hahaha.
Alright.
It's okay.
We're sort of...
We're up...
We're up the bell curve a little.
I swear to god.
Please survive.
Hahaha.
I don't...
Ask for a lot of things.
I just want my team to be alive.
Oh my god.
I need to...
I need to get used to that.
It just always fucks me up.
Which is not good.
I hit my forehead.
Okay.
Get a 2x.
Oh my god.
Please.
I need another gun.
Oh, there you go.
I ask and I got it.
Okay.
I didn't mean to do that.
Hahaha.
Hey, you know like that entire...
That was an accident.
I would...
I didn't even aim for it.
I...
I don't know.
I didn't even aim for it, guys.
I...
I legit...
I didn't even aim for that.
I don't know how I got...
I would shoot my gun too.
Oh my god.
It's so hard to track this.
That's bad.
No!
What ping wise?
I should've got that.
That had a hit register too.
God dammit.
You get an R9?!
Who...
Who gave you blessing?!
Aw man.
Oh wait.
This team.
Nevermind.
No.
God dammit.
Aw, he got an R9 too.
They...
They blessed him.
They actually blessed him.
Wait, Orax became a dev?
Since when?
When did Orax became a dev?
He was a...
Pro.
Did they give all pros...
There's no way.
Wasn't he a pro player?
Yeah.
When did he became a dev?
Or like a caster?
Or was he a ca...
No, he was a pro.
I don't fucking remember he was.
I remember he played.
Yeah.
The fuck he became a...
Evok.
I was like, how did he get a...
I know he was a pro player.
I recognize his name.
No, uh...
Um...
A dev badge is...
Oh!
All badges are...
That's so cheesy!
I forgot!
All badges are available.
So everybody's putting on the dev badge.
I'm so dumb.
I'm...
That actually makes a lot of sense.
Time...
Time to be a dev, guys!
I'm gonna be a dev now.
I'm...
That joke you put on.
Even...
Even I can be a dev, guys.
Oh my god.
Which is nice straight down.
I'm gonna end it.
Just end it.
Alright.
Don't let the intrusion thoughts win, Doki!
Don't let them catch you!
Wait, what?
Oh.
Really?
Is he fucking with me?
He's...
There's no way.
Oh, there is.
Oh my god.
Please!
Where's my team?
Oh my god.
I thought he was with me.
I...
Oh my god.
Oh, he's...
Wait.
That's a new team.
Oh my god.
Goodbye.
I'm sorry.
You're gonna have to go through hell.
It's okay.
I've wanted to...
It's okay, guys.
I wanted...
I didn't realize two people were gonna be like...
He could...
I thought it was one guy.
Alright.
No.
It's okay.
I wanted to die.
So I could do this.
Where's my badge?
Oh my god.
I'm...
My eyes are blurring right now.
Oh my god.
Wait.
It's all bronze.
Thank you.
Hahaha.
Okay.
Wait.
Here.
And then...
Wait.
Where's my...
I'm so tired.
Wait.
Don't miss me.
And then...
Where's the dev badge?
Where is it?
It's...
There you go.
Now I'm a real dev.
I'm...
Hahaha.
Okay.
Uh...
Banners.
Badges.
Finally.
A badge for me.
I've always wanted a rookie badge.
I feel like that's more special.
I think the rookie badge is more special than any other badge out there.
Because it's so hard to be a rookie.
You have to have the time commitment to be a rookie.
Actually not time commitment.
You have to like play one game and then like...
Come back to Apex.
And then play another game.
Hahaha.
Guys.
Oh my god.
I'm part of the respawn team now.
Look at that.
There's my...
I got the dev badge.
Oh my god.
Look at that.
I'm so good.
Uh...
Oh wait.
Does that mean all of this is unlocked too?
Wait.
Do I have the ALGS?
The ALGS banner?
There's an ALGS frame banner right?
I don't remember.
There's like something ALGS related.
That you can get.
Master.
Make your choice.
P2020.
Master.
Prize.
Possession.
Uh...
I don't think she's gonna...
Don't let them say that.
Is there like some ALGS related shit you can get?
To be like, wait is it...
Oh my...
Yes.
That's me!
That's me.
I deserve that.
Oh, you can put like art on this.
Wait.
I didn't realize you can do that.
Oh, this is so new to me.
Okay.
This is Aereo Superiority.
Uh...
I have all the time in the world to customize my banner.
Time to make up!
Guys!
Wait.
You're right.
Guys.
Wait.
You're so right.
Let me take a screenshot.
Give me a sec.
Let me tweet that out.
You're so red.
You're so red!
That's cool.
I have to bring like..
You don't even have to take a screenshot.
No...
Let's go.
Haters will say it's fake.
They're just jealous.
They're just jealous, guys.
Alright, and then... What is this?
Is this ALGS?
Do it for the rush?
I don't even know what this is.
Good luck.
Don't that.
Oh, there's team.
Oh, this is the ALGS.
But this is like supporting them and stuff.
Do you guys think they'll believe me?
Do you guys...
Do you think they'll... Do you think people will believe me?
Add dev or staff in front of your name.
Guys, where was I on the bell curve?
Did I drop down or climbed a little bit?
Oh, I forgot to look at the... the sparrow skin.
I mean, sure.
Haters would say it's fake.
So true.
All they do is hate.
They didn't... They didn't watch the stream where it's so real.
I wish I was champion so I could put that out.
They can only go up, don't keep.
Alright.
Nah.
They're gonna be so scared now.
Oh, my God.
I just needed like a decent team.
And I gotta not throw.
I gotta not troll.
I gotta not throw and troll.
Also, like...
By the way, have you guys noticed that...
Are you...
Okay.
I...
What happened?
But have you guys noticed that I haven't encountered a single R9 for myself to hold?
I don't think I've...
During the whole...
The only time I've actually used R9 was during...
Was during arenas when I bought the R9.
I haven't yet to encounter.
Oh, there it is!
There it is!
Alright, there we go.
I asked...
I complained and I got it.
Never mind.
I'm not...
I guess I just gotta keep complaining.
Speak of the devil!
I'm gonna lose it.
I can feel it.
I give...
Oh, my God.
It's DJ Sneaky Snake.
Do you remember him?
It's just a pal.
Guys, look at that.
I became a dev and now I get every gun I've ever wanted.
Also, guys, I also noticed...
Tomorrow, we won't be doing an Apex stream on Twitch because apparently you have to start at 9 a.m.
Or, like, if you wanna do Battle Royale, it'll be at 11 a.m.
And, like, I'm not strong enough to do back-to-back morning streams.
I...
I can't.
I'm...
I...
To give it to you guys straight, I am not strong enough for that.
Because...
The server closes at 1 p.m.
And...
Like, I guess we'll never...
I'm just a little bit...
And I cannot be that person.
I'm sorry.
I cannot be that person for you guys.
I mean, there's, like, a full team here.
And then there's a team right in Terminal.
Yeah, I can't...
I understand that this is all the Apex content for the early season preview.
Just want more ammo real quick.
Just a little burn.
I have, like, one stack for each gun.
This is not the best.
Alright.
I mean, I'm having fun.
I'm having fun.
I just can't survive back-to-back early streams because I'm not strong enough.
I simply am just one person.
Oh.
They're rezzing.
I know I should press...
I should do the easier way of this, but...
bad habits.
Bad habits and I'll never learn.
I will, maybe, eventually.
Where did it go?
I don't want to waste my jammers because I feel like...
I guess I waste my jammers.
I didn't want to, but...
Where are they?
Did you track them?
Where...
Where are they?
If I die, I die.
Okay, other squad is here.
Shoot the tracker!
It's not like you can't shoot it!
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Thank god, okay.
This is bad for us.
We don't have LOS of it, so we're fine.
I'm like, trying to fight this, but like, we're getting shot from everywhere, which is really difficult.
I think that's the worst part.
There's like, several teams here.
Oh!
Okay.
I have a respawn beacon.
No, it's fine.
I'll res him here.
I think we should go here.
I'm sending him back.
I'm sending you back to hell.
There we go.
Good luck.
Here's your energy ammo that I stole.
I'm not going into this fight by myself, by the way.
I...
Alright, JK, fuck it.
Oh my god, there's another team?
Bro!
Help me!
Oh
my god.
I want to leave this hill.
At least let me fight this hill.
The fun never ends.
Can I leave the hill?
Sucks to be you.
I don't fucking know.
I have one stack.
Bro!
What the fuck?
I see...
Okay.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna...
I don't know where I got shot at.
I really don't know.
I'm getting shot by like 20 different directions and I'm trying to figure out where I can actually position.
I feel like I can't position anywhere.
You know?
That's how I fucked up I feel right now.
At least I killed him.
Jesus.
Thank god I could use my fucking brain.
Okay, that shit has a lot of HP.
That...
Oh my...
I'm getting ammo.
That actually had so much...
I was not expecting how much HP that was.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
I'm going this way.
Okay guys.
Let's just die again.
I don't understand my team.
I...
I don't know what my team...
I don't know what my team wants.
I...
No, you die.
You'll never understand.
I'll never...
I'll never understand my...
my team's brain.
I...
That was...
Wild.
Your...
My team was...
My...
Surely I'll get a good RNG.
I'll...
Just next time.
Next game.
My RNG will improve.
Surely.
Oh my god.
It's DJ Sneaky Snake.
I don't know anymore.
Guys.
It's him.
It's DJ Sneaky Snake.
Guys.
Oh my god.
I should have...
I just don't understand.
I just...
That...
Like...
They were so aggressive for no reason.
There were like 20 different teams around us.
How is this guy still level 1?
I saw DJ Sneaky Snake.
Like...
And he won?
Hey look.
It's me.
I got to be on the champion.
With my brain back.
Oh fuck.
Okay.
I don't...
Do I want to...
Just die?
You could just die.
Yeah.
Fuck it.
I believe in this.
I want my guy to lose his championship.
Let's just...
Die.
Guys.
He's rank 1 like you are a dev.
Okay.
I need that armor slop.
Really bad.
You had two guns?
What is...
Why did...
I
had to fight you too!
Oh my god.
Bro what was this guy doing?
Yeah.
That was my bad.
I let DJ Sneaky Snake...
I let...
I put DJ Sneaky Snake into hell.
I...
Look.
That was my bad.
I put him in hell.
I...
We saw champion.
And I was like...
You are gonna lose...
I'm gonna let you lose champion.
I would admit...
That was on me.
I took him to hell.
I...
But...
I did.
This guy did nothing.
I did do...
I did pull my weight though.
I...
I pulled my weight in hell though.
Look.
I...
I did pull my weight.
I thought...
You know...
Since DJ Sneaky Snake did win...
He did win!
I thought...
He would have pulled this weight too.
I...
Yeah.
I took him to hell because I thought we could make it.
I thought...
I thought we could have made it.
I...
I believe too hard.
I think I went down the bell curve, guys.
Don't worry.
This is it.
You absolutely did.
One day I get to play Sparrow again.
Don't worry.
I believe.
Look at me.
I'm a dev.
That's me.
Alright.
Let's go.
Not getting that gun.
JK.
I'm gonna get the gun.
I'm gonna grab my nemesis.
And now I'm gonna upgrade my nemesis.
And there's no consequences.
Oh.
There might be consequences.
People here?
No!
Fuck!
I have to reload.
It's okay.
Oh, he thirsted.
It's not okay.
I have to reload.
No!
Unlucky.
Wait, how much?
No, I want to see how much HP.
Let me expect it.
Oh my...
Wait, there was two?
There were still two more.
Oh, wait.
They got third party.
Yay!
I should have got vault.
I didn't realize there was a team.
Nemesis was not in.
Yay!
They get thirded!
Yippee!
That's all I care about!
Punished immediately.
Alright, they better lose this fight.
I swear to God.
I'm gonna fucking go running as ballistic if I have to deal with this.
I'm in it.
Oh my God.
Wait, and then they win?
This is not fair.
That's it.
This guy has inspired me.
How dare they not get punished.
I am so inspired now.
Then she will hate watch.
How can I hate watch if they live?
I am inspired.
But then I lose my dev.
My dev powers.
She has the inspiration.
I heard ballistic gets banned a lot.
This is it.
I am inspired now.
I am inspired.
It's over.
I lose my dev bash.
But it's over.
I don't even know.
Were we...
Were we in...
Did we move up in the bell curve?
Did we move up, guys?
That's all I need to know.
Do you know how to play...
Do you know how to play ballistic?
No.
But I got the spirit.
I got the spirit, boys.
It's okay.
I feel it.
I feel the energy.
That makes you happy.
I feel it.
I heard he's really good.
Oh my god.
I got so much spirit.
How about you?
I don't like being in the middle.
But it's okay.
It's not about what I like, I guess.
I forgot to...
Oh my god.
It's the explosive arrows.
No!
I forgot to...
Oh my god.
I forgot to rebuy...
The...
R9 skin.
Oh my god.
This is hell.
I realized that it's not...
It's not the good one.
I am...
Oh man.
That's not good.
I don't know how to aim with this R9 skin.
I actually...
I do not know.
Guys, it's actually over for me.
That skin actually hurts me.
That...
No, I don't know how to use this...
Ironsight.
I need an actual...
Wait, where?
Oh, are we going to Oasis?
I'm not inspired anymore.
Increase alteration.
Should I get this?
I feel like that would be good, right?
I need...
I actually need like...
Not an enemy.
That was Cold Piercer.
Yeah, I'm coming.
I'm coming.
Alright, I'm here.
We're not far from the ring and have 10 seconds to find safe harbor.
Oh my god.
I need an 1x.
I actually don't know how to play.
I was so spoiled.
I played with my pay to win R9 skin for so long in my life that...
I've actually been so spoiled.
Yeah, I need a final 1x.
We're trailing.
We're trailing, brother.
We just need a final 1x.
Oh my god.
Don't worry, sir.
Don't worry.
Let's go in.
Do you have a 1x?
Oh my god.
Let's go.
There's no one here.
Wait, what?
I used my ult for no reason?
Usual?
There we go.
Hey, Sully.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Oh, I fucked up.
That was bad.
I egoed it.
I egoed that.
Oh my god.
Of course it's Daz.
I egoed it.
But I killed Sully though.
Wait, is this the actual Sully?
Was that the actual Sully Sully?
The Korean Sully?
Wait.
Isn't he?
No.
Right?
Yeah, no.
It was aggressive.
No, I...
I can't tell.
You're coming on 5.
I was way too embarrassed.
I thought it was...
One guy.
I got...
I had too much spirit, guys.
Too much spirit?
How about you?
Oh my god.
Look at that.
I wish I was on roller.
I wish I lived that life.
Oh my god.
Look at him go.
Oh, there's a third party.
There's a third party.
Oh, that's unlucky.
Yeah, I was like wondering if that was the real...
Oh my god, peeps.
He's doing it.
He's...
Oh my god.
Good job, peeps.
Okay, I should actually focus now.
There was like 7 teams here.
There was actually 7 teams.
Holy fuck.
Ah, the true Apex Legends experience.
How I missed you.
Are you serious, dad?
They...
They came in last.
And cleaned everything up.
Oh my...
I wish that was me.
Oh, DR9 skin.
You're right.
Let me go back.
I need to rebut.
I need to do it.
The true Thunderdome experience.
Alright.
Let's see.
Banners.
Before I do that...
Before...
This is more important.
Before I do this.
This is much more important.
And then...
Don't worry, guys.
I got this.
No.
Oh wait.
I almost forgot...
The actual thing I was supposed to do.
Sorry.
Now...
Now this is...
Where's my usual gun?
Where is it?
No.
There...
Oh, here.
This is the one I use.
I always use zero point.
The reason why this is pay to win is...
You can see here.
This is...
Here is a circle, right?
And it blocks everything.
Right here.
It blocks everything.
But here is like a straight line.
So like...
The head fits in more.
That's why this is pay to win.
So always...
When you play R9...
You'll just use...
Just get like...
Any scope that has this.
Because like...
This shit is fucking ass.
I cannot see anything.
It's dumb.
Like...
It's dumb that they have pay to win skins.
I hate that concept.
It's same with...
R9.
Okay.
The reason why...
Is because this R9...
This wingman skin...
Is skinnier.
If you look at this...
It's bulkier.
Also like...
Like you can see how much bulkier this is.
Compared to this.
Because it's more like...
It's more like...
You know...
Rectangular.
And then this one is like...
You know...
There's like a...
Thing...
Jucting out right here.
And...
I don't know if that was a word.
I made up a word.
And I know that...
Flatline also has...
Something like it.
But...
I somehow managed to be able to aim without...
What's...
Assault rifle?
Flatline.
Okay.
For flatline.
I don't remember which one is.
Is it...
It's also similar.
Yeah.
It's also the scope.
I'm pretty sure.
Right?
Default is...
What's default?
Default is this.
And then...
The good one is also like...
The heatsink.
Yeah.
This is the...
Play-Doh win skin.
It takes less time.
Yeah.
This doesn't have it anymore.
Did they fix it?
Oh, they fixed it?
Okay.
Oh, it did they?
Nice.
I'm glad.
I remember...
Shotgun...
Peacekeeper had a...
Had one too.
But I don't remember what it was.
Because, like...
I didn't care too much about it.
But...
I know Peacekeeper also had it.
It was the iron sight as well.
But I don't remember a lot about the PK.
Um...
I'm not like...
I mean, this is like knowledge.
Uh...
This is like the...
Like been common knowledge since the beginning of Apex.
That...
A lot of these skins are like...
Pay to win.
Because they have better iron sight.
And that's why people always...
When they're on New York...
They always ask people to reskin their guns.
Because like...
If they don't have this...
Back then...
When people didn't have this pay to win skin.
They would like...
Ask...
Stack with players...
That had the pay to win skin.
And then they'll be like...
Can you reskin my gun?
Like...
And like...
If they want to...
Like you know...
If they still want to have it...
They'll just be like...
Oh yeah...
Can you reskin my gun?
But obviously everyone has it now.
Because like...
It takes...
People have already built enough money...
To have the skins now.
And then...
Yeah...
I would do that.
I would...
I remember when I had to start a new account.
And then I...
Would be like...
I'm playing with someone.
And then, like, you know, I'd be like, do you have the skin?
And I was like, can you reskin my gun?
Because then I have to regrind all the skins again.
Like, all my pay-to-win skins.
Because I fucking hate playing.
I fucking hate playing with the defaults.
Because I was so used... I had so many hours in this game using the default skins.
Oh my god!
I'm pushing the rock!
This is the highest I've ever been on the bell curve!
And there's only two of us!
Okay.
Um...
Wait!
If we were down...
Wait a minute!
How fucked up were my teammates to pull me down the bell curve?
That low!
If two of us are in the middle of the bell curve, how fucking bad were my teammates?
How...
Oh my god!
How fucked were they pulling me down?
The answer is yes.
Oh my god!
And it's just two of us.
Just the two of us.
Bum bum ba dum bum ba dum.
I can't believe two of us managed to be a high...
higher on the bell curve.
Higher on the bell curve.
That's so fucked!
It puts into perspective how fucked up my team was during the entire time.
I'm not running that.
I've learned my lesson.
I've learned my lesson!
How about I get an R&A?
After everything I've been through.
Oh my god, I hear so...
Oh my god, nice!
Nice!
I really want to fight really badly.
But it's just two of us, so I understand that he's like a little hesitant.
Um, I get it.
I understand, I hear you.
Wait, I need to find...
Wait, does he...
What?
Where does he want to go?
I'm ready when you are.
Oh.
Alright, let's go.
But, just the two of us.
Bum bum ba dum bum ba dum.
Just the two of us.
Jesus Christ.
Apparently not.
I should put one in my sling, if.
Fuck it.
Not really here.
Too much.
Always wanted a brother.
Oh.
Oh, I don't know if he saw me.
I don't know if he saw me.
When you kill Lita, absolutely disgusting effort.
What the f...
That's actually fucked up.
Did you guys see that?
I hit an entire mag too.
I'm so sad.
I actually hit an entire mag for that.
Reloaded.
You're killing up.
I'm...
I...
Several no regs.
That...
I'm sad.
I'm so sad.
I...
I hit several no regs for that.
I'm...
Okay.
That's...
That's fine.
I'm okay with hitting several no regs.
I'm...
The world is out to get me.
There's no way the world isn't out to get me.
I refuse.
I'm just gonna put it there.
And then there's him.
The world hates me.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
The world hates me.
Wait.
How do I put this in my sling?
Okay.
There you go.
Alright.
Jesus.
This fight was never gonna end.
I don't think this fight is gonna end, guys.
Wait.
There's people here.
There's a little bit of team right here.
Me and my guy.
We're scared.
Oh, I thought the bullet would be closer.
Not gonna lie.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh my god.
I'm not okay.
Hey, look.
Alright.
Nice.
Just in case I need to, you know, use my ult.
Just in case.
I swear to god, if there's another team that decides to go, like, fuck you.
I swear to god.
I...
That we had to fight, like, we had to fight, like, ten hundred teams just now.
I am not having it.
I...
I don't know.
I don't know if there's another team.
Can't tell.
I'm scared.
I'm scared, man.
I'm so...
Why?
I don't want to lead.
I don't...
Why am I leading?
Stop following me!
Stop!
Oh my god.
I fucking knew it.
I knew it.
I knew.
I fucking knew it.
This is why I did not want to lead.
Jesus Christ.
I'm fucking dead.
I'm fucking dead to this.
This is...
This is my hubris.
Like...
Why are they were all there?
And this is a third party?
How could there be a third team?
How?
How was there a third team?
I stayed there.
And there was still...
There was still a third team.
That's actually crazy.
I...
Why do they want this tiny room?
Oh, I'm back down the...
Oh, they rolled me back down.
They...
They rolled me back down the hill.
And so the bow, they rolls back down.
The hill.
Did you...
Not the bell curve.
No!
I'm sad.
Maybe I was never...
It was never meant to be a ballistic player.
They gave you a third teammate.
Like, I have to be so fucking...
Oh my god.
I have to play so paranoid too.
I'm playing incredibly paranoid.
Every time.
Oh.
I think that's like...
I forgot how paranoid it makes me when I play Apex.
I'm never safe.
That's the secret.
Hey, let's land there.
Alright, down I go.
Down I go.
I do...
I like never left that area.
That was the worst part.
I never left.
I literally...
I got down and it was like party time.
It's like, this is your home now.
And like seven different people died.
Seven different teams died there.
From that one encounter.
Oh my god, thank god.
I forgot how that was like.
I forgot how that was like to live in the mosh pit.
Alright, nice.
You know what?
Maybe I can make it...
No, I can't.
Don't lie to yourself, Doki.
Don't lie to yourself.
You know you can't make...
Make it work.
How?
Oh, that's how.
Controller?
That's how.
Alright, that's fine.
I'm fine to die in this hole.
Oh my god, I fucking thermite myself.
Whoops.
That's my bad.
Okay.
That's actually my bad.
I thermited myself.
I thought I got it correctly.
But I didn't.
God, you're so bad though.
Oh my god.
If I didn't accidentally thermite myself...
If I...
I could have...
Pulled through it.
I...
I'm just trying to figure...
My god, I forgot to thermite position.
All good.
I literally got her 100 to 0.
Bro, hitting...
Well, you know, can't get it all.
It was a psychological that made him think you were bad.
So he would 1v1.
Totally.
That was a low bell curve.
I had a good idea.
But I failed the execution of the name.
I was...
I didn't aim it correctly.
Um...
I...
I didn't...
I had to do it like...
I had to do it in a way where I didn't...
Fuck myself up.
But I did.
But like...
The fact that he lost that 1v1...
Was very embarrassing for him.
Was...
That was embarrassing.
Because I was like...
1v1.
I had no shields.
Maybe I'll find...
I'll find something.
Ruby's bell cruiser.
Alright.
I'll focus up.
I only have like...
15 minutes left at the...
Early access.
15 minutes left.
Alright.
I'll focus up.
I prom...
I'll lock in, guys.
I promise.
No more fucking around.
I'll lock in.
I'll play with my guns.
Okay.
I'll lock in.
This is it, guys.
I'm locking in.
15.
It closes at 1.
That's why I was like...
Oh.
They only have...
But then the thing that sucks...
Is that it starts at 9am.
Like, that's the thing that I hate.
I hate that...
The play test starts at 9am.
Um...
And then it closes at 1pm.
But it makes sense because they want to make sure that...
People...
Are you serious?
Are you fucking...
Oh my god.
I...
I die.
There's no way.
I don't have a gun.
Unless...
Gun time.
I got a gun now.
Okay.
Nice.
We got it.
Oh, thank god.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
We won the fight.
We had...
We had the...
I'm so happy.
Oh my god.
We actually won the fight.
What the fuck?
I had...
My team had guns.
My team has hands!
Alright.
Locking in.
Okay.
Let's see.
I need actual guns.
I want to lock in.
Yay!
I love being a dev.
Yippee!
I love...
I love being a developer.
It's so fun.
That shouldn't be standing in the open.
But...
Yep, I fucking knew it.
Okay.
Good aim.
Need this.
Okay.
We help our guy.
Help our guy.
Coming over.
Fuck!
Okay, fine.
Fine.
That's unlucky.
Let me just sell real fast.
Alright.
Is this another team?
God damn it!
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
Please, chill!
Oh my god!
I'm still playing too much for the team, but I think this is working, though.
I think we're playing for the team is alright right now.
Where is he?
This is... unfortunate, but...
Is that ours?
I don't care.
My god!
And there's more!
Oh my god.
Please.
I'm tired.
Oh my god!
No!
I'm tired!
I'm tired.
I'm so tired.
They're dueled right now!
They're fucking dueled right now!
They're actually... I'm so tired.
I have eight more minutes.
They're dueled too!
For those who don't know, they're all pro players.
Apreeze used to be a pro player.
Deez used to be a pro... is currently a pro player.
I'm so tired.
This is just hell!
Oh my god.
When will the nightmare end?
Can we rest?
I'm playing it.
I'm gonna play it so many other than Ballistic.
Oh my god.
I have to rest all the time.
Can we rest?
Are they three stacking?
I don't know who Wicked Archer is.
I don't know.
I'm so... I'm so tired.
It never stopped.
I never left.
We stayed there until there were six quads left.
That's crazy.
We were there until there were...
It never ended.
People just kept redeploying to us.
That was the worst part.
We just had people redeploying to us non-stop.
The EXPUD situation is...
You know what?
Maybe Arena was not a bad idea.
Maybe...
Maybe Arena was not a bad idea, guys.
No, it's okay.
We have...
Six more minutes.
And then...
If we get in a game in six more minutes, that's our last game.
Arena didn't have a bell curve.
It did not.
It did not have a bell curve.
I think...
I think if I was duode or three stacking, I would be fine.
I would be fine.
The bell curve is, like, fucking me up.
The bell curve hurts, man.
The bell curve really hurts.
Cause I just...
When would I...
The last time I got pro on my team was Peeps.
And, like, he's an MC now.
Like...
I don't know anybody that is not in the stack right now.
That is...
Um...
Maybe I'll do Cat.
I don't know.
Uh...
Fuck.
I'll try Ballistic when we're into...
My last game on Ballistic.
Because, like...
I don't know people that...
Who has early access that's, um...
That's not already stacked up.
Or, like...
They don't have early access.
The players I know.
I was just very tired.
Oh, man.
I was a third party.
I thought it would stop.
But it never stopped.
I thought it would stop!
But they just kept coming, and they just kept coming, and they just kept coming, and they just kept coming...
It never stops.
Alright down I go,
I don't have hope anymore.
Don't say that.
Now I don't believe anymore.
This is my last game.
Oh, no!
No!
What?
Sully!
God damn it.
Okay, if I die, die now so I can re-queue.
Please, die now.
Oh my god, it's Sully.
God damn it, Sully.
No, it's not.
Sully's not a controller.
Wait, who's this fake Sully?
I swear to God, if you die now, I can re-queue.
No, that is Sully.
Oh my god.
Is this actual?
No, please, just die now.
Please, you know it closes in four minutes.
You know it closes in four minutes!
I need my game!
Oh, please.
No, do not.
Do not do this to me.
I'm... I do not.
Do not.
Do not do this.
Oh my god.
Do not do this to me.
I swear to God.
Do I risk it?
Do I...
I have two minutes to get a game.
Do I risk it?
Or do I wait for her to rest?
Yes?
Okay, I'm risking it.
Okay.
No, Sully.
Yeah, Sully plays Apex.
That's what I was like.
Is that... Oh my god.
Look.
One minute.
I swear to God.
I risked it, guys.
I risked it.
This one minute.
I better get that game, guys.
I swear to God.
I have one minute and 23... 20... Oh my god.
Please.
One minute and 16 seconds.
Wait.
Is that actually him?
He used to play Apex.
That's what I was like.
Is that him?
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure that's him.
He's still... Yeah.
I think Sully is... I think that was actual Sully.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm like... Yeah, I'm pretty sure that was.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
This countdown is so stressful.
This countdown is actually so stressful.
I need like... In 35 seconds, I need like 12 more people to join the queue.
I... I need... I need... Come on.
Oh my god.
This countdown is like... I feel like I'm... I'm gonna burst.
17... 16... 15... 14... 13... 12... 11... 10...
Oh my god.
8 players.
Please.
8 people die right now.
No!
No.
They can't do this.
There's no way.
Come on.
Let us in.
You can't close it down yet.
No.
Don't close it down yet.
They did.
Oh man.
Oh wait.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
There's hope.
There's... Wait a minute.
No.
People are leaving.
There's no more hope.
No.
It can't end like this.
I can't... Oh man.
That was the riskiest 50-50 we've ever had.
No hope.
Only cope.
That was a risky 50-50 but... Oh wait.
People can still join.
Wait a minute.
They haven't shut it down.
Wait.
There's still hope.
Come on.
Nine more.
We just need...
It's not over.
Use my death count.
I'll wait.
Three minutes.
But in three minutes, this doesn't go above 51.
It might be over.
Guys.
If in three minutes...
It doesn't go...
Wait.
It went to 52.
Unless...
But this has been so long though.
I don't know guys.
I don't know.
Guys.
How are...
What is my luck?
Are they...
I'm gonna check.
I need to check these players if they're stacking.
I had...
The only person I recognized in my team during Battle Royale was Peeps.
But like, I'm opening up some of the other Apex streamers and they're like literally with like...
They're stacked...
They have to be stacking.
There's no fucking way I was that unlucky in my lobbies.
I see like one of them with like two other Pred players.
Like consistent Pred players and pros.
I'm like...
How?
I got DJ Sneaky Snake.
I...
I got...
I got fucking...
DJ Sneaky Snake.
And the...
Lulu Sushi and ORAX on the same team?
How?
How did you beat the bell curve?
How did you...
Do not diss DJ Sneaky Snake.
He was number one.
Do not diss him.
There's no way I refuse to believe.
Wait.
57.
Oh my god.
It's possible.
Wait.
No.
They actually cued into each other.
That's...
I may or may not be very jealous that...
For some reason.
Lulu.
ORAX.
And...
Um...
They still lost though.
They lost the fight.
But like...
It was Lulu.
ORAX.
And...
Who did I say what third was?
I forgot the third.
They actually randomly got together.
On the same team.
God.
I wish that was me.
There's no way.
That was a natural Q.
Oh my god.
I got LG Kareem Cheese.
I...
Every time I got it.
I get a real player?
No.
Okay.
Thank god.
I was gonna say.
I know LG Kareem Cheese is a real player.
I know he's a real player.
I'm up the bell curve again.
I know he's a real player too.
I was gonna freak out.
But...
I was kidding.
I was not gonna be happy.
I'm gonna callous again.
Fuck it.
Oh.
Nevermind.
I'm surfing that curve.
I'm surfing it.
Yeah.
I'm a dev.
Yippee.
Alright.
That's nice.
I made it past.
The curse.
He decided to give us one more.
One more.
I don't know who Misery Plague is, but I know this person's a real person.
Dropping in.
Hang on.
My dev powers work.
Guys.
Oh my god.
There's Pred Trails too.
I could have equipped my parents.
I could have equipped the Pred Trails.
Oh my god.
I could have equipped one.
What if server stopped right now?
Then life is a cruel fucking joke.
And I'm living it.
Oh my Karim Cheese is down.
They cannot do this to me.
Karim Cheese.
Why did you take me to Sully?
Oh my god.
There's no way.
I got taken to hell again.
I...
Karim Cheese does...
I can't...
Like what...
What do I do?
I did this situation.
They give him just to give me pain.
I...
At least he dies.
You know.
At least...
At least they die too.
Oh.
His life is just unfair.
At least...
I...
At least they die too for that.
Hope to punish you.
Wait.
There's still hope.
Guys.
They haven't shut down the servers just yet.
They haven't done it guys.
They're still...
They forgot to close the servers yet.
They...
Guys.
They haven't.
They haven't closed it.
There's still hope.
Wait.
There's actually a non-Korean Selly?
Oh my god.
There's a...
There's another...
There's a French competitive player?
There's a French pro player.
That's also called Selly.
There's two Apex Selly's?
Yeah.
There's a French Apex pro.
Former pro.
That's also named Selly.
So I was like...
Yeah.
I was like...
Wait.
There's two Selly's?
There's...
What is this Selly first?
No.
It's okay.
They're still on queue.
They forgot to shut it down, guys.
They forgot to shut it down.
Nice.
I'm looking at the chat just to make sure.
I need like one good game, guys.
Just one good game.
Like...
I've been taken to hell every game, I feel like.
I...
Every game, my team took me to hell and then I never came back.
My...
The...
The funny part is that my good games were...
Um...
My good games were...
Mostly...
Arenas.
And I don't...
I don't like that.
What is that no...
Bro!
That's...
Guys...
Maybe it wasn't me.
Maybe it was the bow check.
Okay.
That was four no-regs.
In a row.
Oh, now he hits it.
There you go.
Now it's back.
But that's crazy.
That's actually...
So fucked.
He hit four fucking no-regs.
On a bow check.
That was literally a kill right there.
If he hit it.
Why don't they just shoot the tracker?
It's not that hard.
Alright.
That hit.
At least that hits.
See on a...
Can you answer it too?
Okay.
Now it hits.
At least now it hits, guys.
Yippee!
I hate the car though.
Yeah, I'd be so mad.
No, I'd be very mad.
That was actually an insane no-regs too.
Cause it was like point blank.
It's...
Usually it makes more sense if the no-reg was like really far away.
But it was actually...
It was like point blank too.
So the fact that he...
Missed those shots...
With that was...
Insane.
I would have left the game after four no-regs.
Poor guy.
Yeah.
Four in a row.
Is actually like...
Insane to have...
Happen.
I'm looking.
I'm looking guys.
I'm looking if they shut down the server or not.
I'm making sure.
Don't worry.
I'm not here to be in purgatory.
I'm just making sure the server...
It is.
Don't worry.
The server...
May or may not still be around.
Maybe.
Because...
If Fade is still queuing...
Then it...
We're still in it, baby.
We're still in it.
I'll only stop when Fade stops.
If he stops, I stop.
It's okay.
Plus...
Don't worry.
That really clears it up.
No.
I'm tired.
I'm actually running by pure adrenaline right now.
I'm running on...
Pure fucking adrenaline.
Was that no-rig earlier?
From the first hit?
But we'll see.
What if he stops cute?
Then it's over.
There's no coming back.
I don't know.
I'll try Catalyst next round.
Nice.
Good shot.
Alright.
Next game is gonna be it.
I feel it.
I feel the next game.
Oh, that was a good...
Oh, never mind.
I was gonna say...
That was a piece in tap strafe.
That was a pretty...
Oh, it's Lulu.
Tap...
Doesn't matter.
He tapped strafe in front of a...
In front of a mouse and keyboard player.
Rest in peace.
That was an M and K player.
This is it.
This next game...
No.
Oh, no.
Okay, that's fine.
It's fine.
It's okay.
There's still people queuing.
He's still queuing.
He's...
Fade is still queuing.
No.
Oh, wait.
Was that...
No, you can...
I'm pretty sure you can tap straight with the ability.
Because it's a jump.
Because he, like...
He, like...
He, like, did a...
He did a rotate.
I blew my nose, guys.
I'm too tired to mute right now.
I'm actually...
How do you think about a new season?
I mean...
Honestly...
Okay, I'm not sponsored, by the way.
I...
He just gave me early access.
Honestly...
It's Apex.
Uh...
Nothing...
Is really different...
From...
The last time I played Apex.
It's just...
Different guns are OP.
You know?
So...
Um...
There's more...
Movement play...
Like, it's just...
It's just...
Apex.
I...
I don't know what else to say.
Nothing really has changed much about it.
Uh...
But, yeah, no...
I mean, it's the time to kill.
You can tell that...
People die really fast in this game now.
Even more fast than...
Than in the past.
But, like, I've gotten used to it.
So, like, when you get peak...
Like, they punish you for really poor positioning.
And, like...
Obviously, my positioning isn't perfect.
Because it has been a while since I've played.
And, because it has been a while since I've played.
I...
Don't...
Really have really good positioning.
As I did in the past.
So, I do get punished really easily.
By better players.
I get punished really easily.
Who have...
Who, like, notice I have bad positioning.
Um...
And I obviously...
I can't ego.
I can't ego people.
It seems a bit slower this patch.
I don't know if it is slower.
I can't tell.
Because I didn't play.
But when I played that time...
When I played the patch where...
Um...
When I played...
The patch...
With...
When they first introduce the time-to-kill.
I played one session of it.
And then I stopped.
Because I did not like the ttk.
Um...
Just because, like, I was not happy with... I was just not happy with the TTK, um, for it.
And so I can't tell if the TTK is better or not, but I just, um, I just, I didn't play a lot after that.
Oh my god, Brownstreet... Okay, let me not watch this person.
Let me watch someone else.
Let me, let me watch someone else after that.
Yeah, like, yeah, no.
Come on, I know there's people that still wanna play.
Come on!
We can still make one more lobby!
We can still make one more lobby.
I hope there's more people watching the finals.
Um, as my pro friends were messaging me about it.
And, like, um...
I, I feel like, I feel like, I think it's just a hundred teams play thing.
I think there was a lot of, there was, like, uh...
Yeah, the LAN finals, yeah.
Yeah, they're actually there.
They're at the LAN finals.
I wasn't happy about the TTK changes.
I was just wasn't happy about it in general.
I think, like, I just don't like low...
I mean, like, if I want low TTK, I just play Call of Duty or some shit.
You know?
Like...
But the thing about Call of Duty is that I can respawn.
Um...
I, I can respawn really, really fast.
You know?
If I'm playing...
If I'm playing, like, like, Call of Duty or something.
But if I'm...
Oh my god, it went down.
It went down.
Oh my god, no.
Oh no.
It went down.
Fade!
Don't stop.
Cue!
It's over.
Oh my god.
No!
It's officially over!
Fade stopped queuing!
Fade!
I can't.
This can't be my last game.
Guys, I can't.
I can't.
I refuse to let this be my last game.
I'm pulling it up.
This is it.
It's time for a quick normal Apex game.
This can't be it.
I'm not satisfied.
At all.
This is it.
Totally not.
No, I just need a good game.
That's the...
That's the adrenaline that's been...
I've been streaming for four hours.
Because...
I need a decent game.
Those games I had were so...
They were like...
Not it.
It.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha...
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Don't worry, I'm messaging people.
I mess...
I padded it with randoms.
This is...
I'm...
I'm hungry for victory.
I need a good win, and then I sleep.
And then I can...
rest easy.
I did not wake up at 9 a.m.
to not have a good game.
I... I did not wake up this early just to deal with that bullshit.
For my battle royale.
Oh!
I missed my...
Alright, let's see.
Alright.
Alright, don't worry.
Give me a sec.
Let me... Let me... I'll do, like, one... I'll do, like, a quick duo.
Real fast.
Alright, here you go.
I'm calling... I'm calling... I'm messaging people.
One good game is all I need!
And I'll be satisfied.
I can die happy.
I... No longer a prey dev.
No longer a dev.
No longer will I get to use my powers.
Alright.
I'm... Solo.
I should play...
Something... More... More... More, like, actual... Unga Bunga.
But fuck it.
It's okay.
Alright.
I believe.
She got spirit.
I got spirit, guys.
I got spirit.
How about you?
I don't know.
I don't play duos.
Hahaha.
I don't... I don't play duos.
I don't know.
Alright.
Where are we landing?
Um... Is that still the plan?
Yeah, I'm gonna get ready accomplished for one game.
I'll do...
How are there no...
What?
There's no way.
Was this a house with zero guns?
Oh my god.
That was a house with zero guns.
That...
I got spirit.
How about you?
No more...
No more dev luck.
I still got spirit, guys.
Despite the circumstances.
I still got that spirit.
I...
That terrible...
Terrible spirit.
What?
My god left ins...
Oh my...
The ring closes in one minute.
Okay.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
I got him.
No.
It's okay.
I...
Oh, okay.
That's...
I know what...
Real aim assist.
Let's go.
Aim assist.
It's okay.
It's all right.
I still...
I'm...
Do I wait?
Okay.
I'm waiting for...
All right.
You know what?
I'm gonna angry pee.
And then I'll be right back.
And...
I...
Be right back.
Defending me.
I'm angry.
That's it.
I'm gonna take it out on you.
That's right.
Now you'll never be my friend.
That's fucking right.
I'll do it again.
Bad.
What's your...
Who was it?
Who was straight?
I'll give you a mod if you tell me you're straight.
Who is it?
Who's straight?
It was I.
That's it.
I'm bad.
It's a trap.
I'm gonna take it out on you.
And I'm gonna bad you.
What did I do?
That's right.
I'm angry.
I need to let this out on someone.
That's right.
Go in.
Time out, corner.
But now you're gonna pay.
Daddy's angry.
Angry and tired.
As expected.
I'm not stable right now.
Poor shit.
That's not a full effect.
Oh, you wanna test me too, D-Dragon?
That didn't mean...
Don't worry.
I'm putting on a shirt real quick.
Do you have spirit?
Okay, I'll do it.
Look at how they massacred my bird.
Wow.
I am not...
Daddy's angry.
Lucy!
Daddy's angry!
It's okay.
I'm okay.
Wait, okay.
Someone responded.
I messaged like...
Three people.
Fine, I don't care.
I'll take anything.
I'll take it.
Alright.
This is it.
This is my one game.
That's not my one game.
I swear to God.
If this person doesn't...
Doesn't...
Pull up.
I'm kidding.
I'm...
I'm banning them from my channel.
I...
They'll never be able to...
BM on my channel.
I'm banning them on my channel.
And also on my Twitch, too.
I...
That's right.
Daddy's angry.
Alright.
Let's go.
That's rough.
Don't worry.
Uh...
Quiet.
You do not speak.
No rights.
Yoki angry.
One good game.
That's all I need.
And I'll be happy.
All right.
The power of views.
It's okay.
He has his YouTube link.
So I know what his channel name is.
I...
I know.
All right.
Let's go.
Doki angry.
I'm tired and I'm angry.
I have lots of struggles.
I will walk all over.
All right.
This is it.
I shall feel...
It's just...
I will feel joy today.
And I can finally rest.
It's like...
Okay.
For anyone that...
I don't...
I normally don't watch Doctor...
I don't watch Doctor Who.
But there was a viral episode recently.
That was related to like...
Don't make me laugh.
Like that animation guy.
What was it?
I don't remember his name.
But like he's like...
He's really quirky and whatever.
But...
The...
Yeah.
It was...
There was a recent Doctor Who episode.
And...
It was based off of like this...
This animated guy.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
What was his name?
I don't remember.
It was based off of like...
Rupert.
Mr. Ring-a-Ding.
Yes!
Okay.
That's his name.
And he was in the doctor...
I actually like...
Really enjoyed this episode.
I watched like little moments of it.
Because I thought it was like...
Really funny.
And really cute.
And then like...
In the end of the episode...
The thing is...
He was like...
A god of light or whatever.
And then he ascended into heaven.
Into like the universe.
And then faded out.
Because all he wanted was light.
But because the sun gave him light...
He like...
Fucking grew bigger and bigger.
And then he grew so big.
And then he ascended into a universe.
And then just...
Faded out and disappeared.
And he was like...
He's like...
I did it.
And then a tear dropped back.
That's me.
Yeah, he merged with the atmosphere.
The moment I win that one game, I will be him.
I shall ascend to the universe and merge into the atmosphere.
I know that's like a reference that only 1% of you got.
But you... Please, YouTube MrRingading ending.
And then you'll... I'm gonna give you guys that clip.
When we win that game, I'm giving you guys that clip, and you'll understand, like, how I feel.
You'll... You'll understand.
I'm too far.
God.
I know, I'm speaking, like, in tongues right now.
I'm so fucking tired.
I've been streaming Apex for 4 hours.
I'm fucking exhausted.
And I've had 3 hours of sleep.
I'm just too far gone.
Yeah, I'm way too far gone.
Don't make me laugh.
Ha ha ha.
Ba ba dum.
Boom boom boom.
One minute.
We have time to strategize.
I don't even... I should...
Oh yeah, this is like...
Pre-nerf.
So...
I should grab...
Grab...
And then...
This is pre-nerf, so I can do this.
And then I'll just do this.
And then I'll get double.
Yeah!
Don't make me laugh!
Alright.
I'm going to fight!
I don't care!
We fight!
We're not pussies!
I need to feel something.
No, I meant the P20.
They nerfed the P20 a little, apparently.
Anyone land on that side?
No.
God damn it!
Nobody landed here!
Nobody...
Nobody landed here.
It's...
Bronze.
He has zero.
I went through hell!
I had to fight pro players!
I had to fight pros and ex-pros!
This is bronze elo!
Pro players on controller!
That's the worst combination!
Bro...
I just went through that for three hours straight.
This is nothing.
I'm going to get absolutely demolished.
I ran out.
After saying that.
I can feel it.
I can feel karma slapping me in the face.
And going...
And being like...
Knock, knock!
Where is anybody?
I'll go that way?
Oh no, he's coming to me.
Okay.
I'm taking this!
Will I die?
It's time to find out!
The support player is going all in!
No one was here.
Doors aren't open.
Where the fuck is...
Oh my god.
Actually, I shouldn't be so cocky right now.
I'm not okay.
I should not be so cocky.
With like the amount of energy I have.
I've cooked too hard.
It's overcooked.
It's fine.
I don't need streamer mode.
I don't need it.
I need...
Like...
Please, let me kill one person.
Let me at least kill one team.
Where the fuck is anybody?
I don't know the rotations in this.
In this area.
Where?
Oh my god.
I'm going to...
Fuck this.
I'll take that.
I'm gonna go...
To Cascade.
There's always people.
Oh shit!
Nice.
Where is he?
Oh, he ran off.
That's fine.
It's fine.
I'm okay.
Let me in.
I want to fight!
I only got delayed because of that fucker.
For throwing in a fucking balloon at me.
We're astray.
Mons!
Give him another time out.
I didn't get that kill, so now I'm extra angry.
Daddy didn't get that kill, so daddy's mad now.
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh my god, no.
Wait, daddy's scared.
Daddy's scared.
Wait, daddy was not expecting that.
Was not expecting the third part.
Jesus, he's one.
He's actually...
Okay, that's fine.
Nice.
Okay, I'm not angry anymore.
You don't have to ban him.
Don't worry.
I'm not angry anymore.
I'm fine.
It's okay.
He can be unbanned now.
I got a kill.
Too late.
No, no.
It's fine.
I'm okay now.
I'm okay.
I'm satisfied.
I'm mood-dependent moderation.
As it should be.
There's so much power in my hands.
I shall use it for not good.
I have been sated.
My blood first has been satisfied.
Their jail first...
It's fine.
Where are they?
Where actually are they?
I hear them healing.
Yeah, up high ground.
Fuck this.
Oh, what the fuck?
Where am I?
That has cover?
They took off the cover?
Since when?
I don't know.
I clearly don't know this map anymore.
Hello?
Let me kill.
Where's the door?
I don't know where the door was.
Alright.
I was so confused.
Alright, nice.
Where?
Okay, let me enhance this.
Alright.
Oh, I should grab ammo.
I'm not thinking right now.
I'm not thinking.
I want a frag!
I'm going this way.
There's surely something over there, right?
Knock, knock.
Knock.
He's only half the battle.
Hello?
Where are people at?
Who's there?
Anything is funny to me now.
That's how gone I am.
I don't see anybody.
Wait, our ass should know.
He has like...
Oh my god.
I think I almost took someone down with me.
I was too bloodthirsty.
Why are you running?
Oh my god.
Oh, he's won.
He's won.
No way.
He's actually won.
No.
Res me, please.
I'm so resable.
Please.
I'm actually so resable right here.
Gomez, I swear to god.
Res me or I kick.
The old me would have let you rot.
Get down again.
And I still might.
I might die though.
100%.
XD.
It's a new team.
Oh.
No.
I... You have no... Oh my god.
There is another team!
There is a...
Oh my god.
To say he has no right to talk.
And then a new team showed up.
Oh my god.
I was like, who gave you that right?
To speak to me.
Oh my god.
Okay.
That's fine.
I'm okay.
We're okay.
Oh wait.
It's a yellow bin.
You know what?
That's good.
Where did they all come from?
Jesus Christ.
Where did all these people come from?
I'm going back up.
I didn't learn my lesson.
I'm going back up there.
I didn't learn my lesson, guys.
Let's go.
Wow.
It's right here.
I'm going to just freely run.
Oh, he saw me.
He saw me.
That's fine.
Ooh.
Nice shot, though.
I was trying to jiggle peek that.
Oh.
Come on.
It's fine.
You know what I have?
Wait.
I had that, too.
Yeah.
I had that, but...
Alright.
Let's go.
I had that, too.
Alright.
Where do we go?
We follow.
Where is he going?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
We're going straight back in it.
That's right.
Oh, shit!
What?
Yeah.
He's still aiming?
Freak!
Fucking freak!
Oh, no.
I don't have ammo.
Reloading.
Below me.
Oh, no.
I don't have ammo for this.
I need energy ammo.
This brawn is so good, bro.
That's what I'm saying.
This is brawn.
What the fuck?
I need ammo.
Oh, my God.
Fuck this.
This is my ammo.
Jesus Christ.
I might need to put this scope in.
I cannot do it with R9.
It's too far.
I need energy.
I'm out of energy.
I'm going in.
I'm going...
This is it.
Wait, we could craft.
You're right.
Or...
Oh, my God.
I'll go craft.
I need a craft.
Oh, I could craft him.
This is clearly more important.
There's no way.
I was going to say there's...
I was going to say...
I could...
Guys, I don't have a res beacon.
Like, what was I...
What am I supposed to do?
What am I supposed to do with no res beacon, guys?
We have no res beacon.
There's...
There's nothing we can do.
See, look.
He's a team player.
I'm not.
That's just the way...
The cookie crumbles.
How is there still five squads?
It gets...
Shh.
I...
I can't, guys.
There was just no other options, guys.
Shh.
There was just...
There was no other option.
No, no, no.
I don't know what you're talking...
I'm giving a res beacon?
I don't know what you're talking about.
The...
I was just...
My hands were tied.
Okay, am I gonna do something crazy?
Yeah.
I was...
He's gonna full heal.
Oh, my God.
The ego.
The ego push.
Oh, my God.
No, not the ego push.
Where?!
Stop!
Oh, my God.
My hands are shaking.
Oh, my God, my hands are shaking.
How?
Oh my god.
He's dead!
Please.
Oh my god.
Please for the love.
Is it all solos?
No, it's not.
No, it's not all solos.
No.
Wait, why are you in my lobby?
Oh my god.
Oh god.
It's okay.
I'm fine.
I'm sad.
Wait, no.
Not.
I need a win.
I'm not.
Also, why are they in my lobby?
I have an excuse.
I haven't played in a while.
Oh my god.
Okay, this is an actual silver bronze player.
I'm not satisfied.
I need a win.
I did my part.
I did.
I was only 200 damage less.
I did my part.
I always did DJs.
Oh my god.
You did amazing.
Amazing.
I did my part of the bargain.
We did carry.
We did equal amounts of damage.
And he insed.
I 1v4 just then after he died.
Did he 1v4?
No, No, he 1v2'd.
I 1v4'd.
I had two more and more.
I need to refill my water.
Give me a sec.
He also talked.
I said no talking.
Daddy needs to focus.
I need to focus.
He says no talking.
Are you a little tired?
I am.
I have 3 hours of sleep.
Before the early access.
Wait, let me...
I'm sorry.
I'm...
I had 3 hours of sleep.
There we go.
That should be...
Then people will know.
Now people will know why I'm like this today.
Alright.
It's okay.
It's fine.
I'm okay.
Too angry to sleep.
Dude, know why now.
Oh my god.
No, that's not an R9.
That's not an R9.
What do I do when it's not an R9?
Wait a minute.
What?
How did he know I was looking?
Dude.
That's crazy that he knew I was looking.
I wasn't there anymore, you fucking idiot.
That's fine.
That's not fine though.
Guys, I need help.
No!
I...
The other gun!
Oh my god.
I swapped to the other gun.
Oh, that's bad.
I swapped to the other gun accidentally.
That was unfortunate.
Oh, okay.
Anger.
No!
It's so low!
Yay!
No more anger.
Calm.
Anger no more.
Anger.
Anger has dispersed.
I clearly got ran at by three people.
What the fuck was wrong with them?
Oh my god.
It's been a while.
Calm.
We'll keep this load up for now.
Anger gone.
Doki satisfied.
Alright, I res.
Doki res.
I might be a little angry that they won't try to run at me.
1v3.
Might be a little angry.
And I cracked all three of them, like, four fucking times.
But it's okay.
Sometimes life is like that.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh my god.
What the fuck is the R9?
They can't do this to me.
I deserve an R9.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Open.
Open crate.
Oh, where's the crate?
Where's the big crate?
Where's the nice big crate?
Where is it?
Is it up here?
How do you get up here?
You see that red thing?
What the fuck?
Where is it?
How do you...
Where?
I don't understand.
I'm tired.
I'm not.
I don't understand.
I've given up.
Hello?
If he...
No.
He's not getting that.
I refuse.
Over there.
Alright.
We go.
It is our destiny.
I'm running on fumes.
Wait, is that R9?
Oh my god.
There is a god.
Why?
Why are you running in the open?
Oh my god.
Okay.
My teammate decided to run in the open.
And now I have to...
Do this.
And now I have to do this.
And hope...
My...
Wait, is that two teams?
Wait, this is...
Is that two teams?
Wait.
Wait a minute.
This is two teams, right?
Why else would they have a cross?
Man.
No, they just...
Actually, no it's not.
Wait, no it is.
Wait, it is.
Two team, why?
Why?
Play for team?
Let's try.
You know what?
The one time I decided to be a good person.
God, I wish I had a scope.
Scope moments.
Two team, why?
I'm not...
Nice, okay.
I wish I had a scope though.
Jesus.
Above us.
What?
Gomez, no!
How do you get up?
I don't know how to get up.
Guard me, guard me, guard me.
Shield, shield, shield.
Jesus Christ.
I don't know how to...
Get up.
Oh, I should...
Fucking, okay, there you go.
What's going on?
What the fuck?
Wait!
Wait, okay.
Also, controller?
Controller?
Okay.
I...
I won't say much.
I'm just gonna have this on the screen.
I'm...
I'm just...
I'm gonna have...
I'm gonna have this on the screen.
Just for now.
I embrace the YouTube.
If I speak, I am in trouble.
I shall not speak.
I shall...
Let the stacks speak for themselves.
One player is signed...
To one of the best teams...
In pro play.
The other person...
Plays...
Plays for fun.
Which one is it?
Wait, really?
Cuban is signed?
Oh my god!
Guys!
Both players play Marvel Rivals!
You can't say that!
Bottom of the curve.
A person that works hard could never beat a person who is having fun.
It's fine.
This is it.
This is the game.
I shall push the rock on top of the mountain!
I can see it now!
The rock will be on top of that mountain!
The rock will be there!
I can see it!
In my vision!
Why are you here, Kazumi?
I can't believe we are still going.
After seeing that bell curve for like three hours straight, like...
You know why.
I saw that bell curve.
It never went up.
It only went up when I lost the third person.
That was how fucked up it was.
The fact that the bell curve only went up when my third player was gone.
Was when I knew things were not what it seems.
There's people over here.
The way in the distance.
The 20, 20 here.
Okay.
Nice.
Wait, what the fuck...
Oh my...
God, he has an R9-2!
You?
Again i have to hell-marry this shot.
Unless... i mean one is down, so.
Nice... he is gonna heal then.
that's the new team.
I'm full of healing.
i'm full healing.
i'm full of healing, thats a new team.
Okay, I'm coming to help him.
Jesus Christ.
I'm trying to make sure, like, I'm not getting flanked at all.
Okay, I'm locking in a little.
Oh!
How are you still trying to kill me?!
Oh
my god.
Where it is?
How?
When did bronze become like this?
I... There's no... I'm fucking... I'm going in.
I'm going in.
Jesus Christ.
This is some bronze?!
I'm coming back right now.
I believe.
I don't understand how bronze became like this.
This is actual.
This is hell.
No, I can't do it.
Alright, I'm coming.
I'm going up.
I... We don't get any... I hear footsteps.
The fact that I had to, like, look at 20 different people that entire fight... Over here.
Oh.
Wait.
You get shot by a different team?
Wait, no.
That's a third party.
That's a... That's a... That's unlucky.
I was like, wait a minute.
That's another team.
I have the bat.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, hey, good.
Oh, my god.
I don't have any bats left.
There's no way we're in bronze-silver lobbies now.
I... I refuse to believe that.
No, I'm gonna get... Oh, my god.
I swear to god.
Oh, my god.
I'm gonna go.
And there's another team!
Oh, my god.
That's another team!
Just... Just... Oh, my god.
That's... That's another team.
I... Oh, my god.
I... That's... Okay.
You're fine.
Alright.
There we go.
The ride never ends.
My circuits are connecting again.
Okay.
I'm okay.
I... We just had...
A lot of teams.
We just had... A lot... A lot of teams.
Wait, what?
Oh, my god.
They rezzed.
They... They rezzed.
They actually... They rezzed.
I'm gonna do something really fucking dumb.
It worked.
I'm dumb.
I swear... I... I will punch you!
I know!
He got the punch now!
I forgot.
The punches don't auto anymore.
Punches don't auto.
I'm just... Oh, my god.
I need to remember punches don't auto anymore.
I... I can't!
I can't!
Oh, my god.
I need... I can't.
Let's go over there!
Oh, my god.
I need to... I threw that.
I... I crashed out.
I'm sorry.
I crashed out with my... I crashed.
She's out.
I... I... The one time I fully crashed out...
It just... This assist no longer works.
Bro, I... There was no breaks that entire fight.
That was my bad.
I take full blame for that.
I crashed out during that.
I take full blame.
If I didn't spend my time fucking trying to punch that guy instead of reloading my gun.
No, it's okay.
I'm okay.
Oh my god.
I threw that fight really hard.
I could have killed her and then we would have been able to reset.
But I let my personal hate get the best of me.
I let my hate control me there.
I won't do that again.
No, the last lobby we had was supposed to be a bronze-silver lobby.
That did not feel like a bronze-silver lobby.
I'm sorry.
That did not...
That did not feel like bronze-silver.
I got... Yeah, I went to the dark side.
I got... My dark... My intrusive thoughts got the better of me.
I went to the dark side.
No, I'm not in early access anymore.
I'm doing like normal games.
I'm... I'm doing normal ranked games.
Cause like... Early access was like...
It was something.
Alright.
Yeah, I was like... These did not feel like the games I played at 3 in the morning.
The games I played at 3 in the morning was so relaxed.
You know what?
I just feel a little inspired.
Yeah.
Alright, who's shooting?
No, that's what I'm saying.
I'm not relaxed.
Oh.
I haven't...
I hit players in smoke?
Haha.
But not...
Not when they're like, right there?
Jesus.
Oh, that's...
Oh, no.
Okay, fuck it.
Oh.
Fine.
I got this.
Alright.
Full focus.
I don't have a shield for you, so don't...
What?
Hello.
Okay.
I don't know where they are.
Am I kidding me?
Give me my...
Oh, my God.
There we go.
Jesus.
Oh, my God.
They are not getting back off from that.
Okay.
That's fine.
He can't shoot.
Jesus.
I was gonna be like, please.
Please.
Wait.
That seems like two.
Two or three.
What's over here?
One.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
Should have stucked up in this chair.
Nice.
Okay.
I was gonna be like, please, I...
I need the arm shield.
I need...
Wait, I'm not upgraded?
I need to use my FBs.
I do that out of habit.
I need this.
Okay.
Fuck.
I'm okay.
I don't know why.
Fuck it.
It's a triple take day.
Sometimes I just gotta believe.
If I start believing, things will go my way.
Whee!
I'm okay.
If I start to believe, things will go my way.
Whee!
Who's gonna tell her?
Tell me what?
Things are gonna go my way!
Hey!
I lied when I said it's a triple take day.
I lied.
It's never a triple take day.
Wait, I wanna grab that shield.
I wanna grab shield uppy.
I don't know what it's called anymore.
My...
I don't know.
Yellow shield uppy.
He he he he he he.
Our odds keep getting better.
Yeah.
Where are we going?
Oh, follow me.
I find...
Evo!
Evo Cash.
I remember now.
Alright.
I aim.
Things die.
That is my lie.
I am a DPS player.
In this game.
Alright.
We go right side!
We can...
I have no attachments on my guns!
Oh!
That's bad!
I think my manager might be mad that I'm still streaming.
Apex.
Hahaha.
It was supposed to be done.
A while ago.
Hahaha.
Sorry!
Whoopsie!
Whoa, that's aggressive.
Now they all...
Now the entire...
China knows we're here.
I don't like this.
Oh my god, I knew it.
I had that feeling when they took that zip.
Jesus Christ.
Can I actually run for me now?
Fuck.
No, I knew it.
I knew it.
Fuck.
Are you serious?
Oh my god!
Ah!
Everyone came for me!
Oh my god!
It's fine.
Last guy is here.
No.
No, you cannot die.
You cannot die.
I don't know if I trust Obama Rose Toy.
I... I don't know.
I don't know if... Wait, that's a different team.
I just realized... I just realized that might be a different team.
All right.
I trust Obama.
Oh my god, Obama did it!
That's... That actually is a new team.
I heard, like, grenades.
Oh, please tell me there's... Oh my god.
Oh my god, please.
I need these attachments.
I don't care.
I know my team got shot at.
But I really needed those attachments.
Okay.
Don't cut up!
Alright, that's good.
You killed an enemy.
Oh my god, thank god.
I killed that hooligan.
Alright, there we go.
Obama!
Welcome back.
You're back, sir.
The other guy fucking left like a pussy.
You got a mess.
Okay, he's just gonna res.
Like, I don't fucking know what he's gonna do.
The third term.
Welcome back, Mr. President.
Dude, you're just gonna res.
Like...
He's just gonna crap and res.
Welcome to Apex Legends.
Is that it?
We're people!
Oh wait, actually I shouldn't say that.
That was like hell.
We're in the next ring.
That was actually hell when they kept coming and they didn't stop coming.
Oh, they did it.
A champion fell.
Look, see, I told you.
Whoever did that.
They res.
No need to make a fuss.
I told you they were gonna do that.
This is our...
Look, there he is!
There he is!
They did it!
Congratulations!
That's the team we killed, guys.
They did the thing.
That's them!
You close your eyes.
They feel like nothing.
Change that off.
Oh.
I hit those.
Nice.
Of course I hit those, Doki.
That's right.
Come in through that door.
Yippee!
Oh hey, peacekeeper.
Okay.
Yay!
I was gonna feel like...
Alright, nothing for Doki.
Wait.
Oh, that's us.
I mean, they're fighting like, on the other side.
We leave?
You know what?
Let's leave.
Nah.
No, I don't need it.
It's dirty.
Oh shit.
Of course the one time, I decided to like...
Fucking stand in the open.
I swear to god.
I...
The one time...
I decided to stand in the open!
The one time!
How is my name?
What?
Har fast! Because...
Is not a Doki day.
Alright.
I trust Obama.
Obama, you got this.
We still have Obama.
He'll save us.
He's here for us.
Oh my god.
Is that a new team?
I cannot tell.
Oh my god.
I let it in correctly.
I let my shots wrong.
Oh!
Okay.
I don't know where people are.
That's a little issue.
Everyone's way too split.
We're all so far apart from each other.
I'm a little nervous because of it.
That's okay.
Don't fucking walk up here, I guess.
I just want to make sure they don't walk up.
Oh, they're all over here.
Okay.
What is this fight?
What the fuck?
What?
Where is going on?
I'm so confused.
Where did everybody go?
Did everyone go- went to zone?
Oh, I see them.
Yeah, they did.
They did.
Where- What go on?
No, I need a hit.
We have to take the balloon.
Let's take the balloon.
Take the balloon.
Take the balloon!
Take the balloon- oh, wait.
They can't.
Wait, we might be fucked.
Guys?
I mean, I got through.
I got through.
I- Why evac when I'm through?
I already made it.
I don't- I don't listen to people who are not allowed to speak.
All right.
Nice.
Wait.
They're rezzing.
Wait a minute!
They're rezzing!
Oh my god, I stood on the rock.
That was a mistake.
Nice!
There you go.
Pew pew pew!
They have their guns.
I stood on- Fuck.
Poor.
What's that unlucky?
Where did it go?
Jesus Christ, that is- No!
Duck hunt.
I accidentally duck hunted.
Wait, somebody.
He died to ring.
Jesus, I almost killed him too.
All right.
I almost killed that guy.
Don't get the cross.
It's dumb, but it works.
Recharging my shields.
One sec.
Oh my god!
Gomez!
Gomez, you fucker.
You fucker, Gomez.
Gomez.
Not today, Capatib.
We've got people depending on you.
All right.
Recharging my shields.
One sec.
Okay, we gotta get in there.
It's all right.
I have more of this.
I needed that.
All right, we wait.
I don't mind playing a little bit, pussy.
We stay, we stay.
They have to come to us.
I know, I just want to grab that.
Wait, who gave him...
Who allowed him to speak?
Chad!
Did you give him permission to speak?
Over here.
All right.
What?
That's right!
And this better not change!
What are we looking at?
I'm curious.
What is over there?
Wait, the other squad?
Wait, what's going on?
Wait, what the fuck is going on?
What is going on in there?
In this tiny hole?
Wait, there's some...
What the fuck?
There's something over there!
Okay, that...
What the...
What the fuck is that game?
I think we had zero grenades!
What the fuck?
What is...
This is a bronze silver lobby.
I...
Oh...
Man...
I...
Bronze players are so good now.
Like...
Braun... Braun...
Braun-Silver players are so good now.
Like, when did that happen?
She can now go...
Oh my god.
Oh hey, I'm going.
How many?
Whoa, 687.
Nice.
That's true.
They all know how to...
They all know how to aim.
That's actually...
Or maybe it was gold.
I don't remember.
Was it gold lobby or silver lobby?
We're free.
Yay!
I'm satisfied.
I am happy now.
Alright, thank you everybody for coming.
To watch.
For checking the early access.
I'll just check...
I'll check back in a couple more months.
Back to Apex when anything else changes.
Um...
Brain tired now.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Maybe it's cause like...
I'm really delirious right now too.
So I have camp.
I'm not playing as well as I should be.
You can tell...
My best performance was definitely the first couple of games.
Before...
And then I just started...
I...
Mentally, I was not...
I was...
I crashed.
I...
But I had fun in the end.
I had fun.
But thank you everybody for watching.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Pause your check.
Get a move around to get that blood flow.
If you stay up for me, it depends.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everyone.
Bye guys.
Thanks for watching five hours of Apex.
It feels just like the good old days.
Doesn't it chat?
Just like the good old days.
Anyway.
I'll see you guys.
Bye guys.
Bye.